so you can
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody how you doing out
there my name is thomas dobasiolo
whatever you want to call me this is
marty o'neil what's up what's going on
this is the dopes usual podcast we're
talking about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between we're trying our best not to get
demonetized all right so here we go guys
very very fun episode about to happen
you guys ask all the time once again
bringing back eric khan how you been i'm
great man thank you for being here thank
you for having me
every time i watch shows and they say
introducing and i just hear yeah
so i was kind of waiting there like
oh yeah man we're just us three here we
go
so how have you been man i've been great
man you've been great you've lived your
life with nine months now oh yeah it's
just getting more and more used to it
man around there right yeah yeah just
about just about be coming up there and
uh just becoming a cali man you know
yeah yeah
texas and california or cousins they're
really close for sure for sure
especially with like certain cities like
austin being like a mini miniature la
it's pretty damn close it's cool where
were you from i was born in austin live
there a few years and then san antonio
yeah i knew it was something else okay
so you've been out here because i
remember last time you came well the
first time you came on the show you had
been here for eight days yeah everybody
asked me like millionaire for eight days
how you liking it i'm just having a good
time
so what's been going on with you since
you've lived here what is are you know i
should say this more direct
right now because i see you post
non-stop yeah you eat a lot of crazy
[ __ ] oh you need a lot of fancy-ass
looking foods have you watched this
video
now with that no he eats a lot of cool
like stuff like designer food
looks cool man wherever you go it's just
awesome looking right what are the top
three spots that you've been going back
and forth because i know you're in texas
and that's a big food state too right
100 la's more of like okay we have a
niche of this here right right so where
are you going all the time uh
first spa probably any
any uh shabu shabu spot you know what
that is so that's uh i don't even know
what it means but you're supposed to say
it as you dip it in but it's a big ass
it's a hot pot
big ass boiling pot of just soup base
whatever and then you get raw meat dip
it in there cooks like in 10 seconds and
then you eat it and it's it's wild it's
delicious like for the table you guys do
the same nah it's it's sometimes on the
table but most of the time at these
restaurants you'll have an individual
bowl in front of you
you're cooking meat inside boiling ass
water yeah yeah yeah it's like it's it's
fire i don't even know
it is yeah i mean that's how you cook
meat right i mean in boiling water all
right it's like boiling soup you know is
it thin
yes it's thin it's slices of like real
quality meat you know we gotta go for
sure i took goblin um the other week i
mean when you guys came to my house yes
sir oh i saw it then i know exactly what
you're talking about
yeah that was a whole different spot
though so that's like my number two spot
that's like uh uh japanese barbecue you
just nice little array just a
barbecue little pit
charcoal hard real yeah real quality
meat that's the biggest thing i mean
every every spot will have its different
little girl style they're all different
i mean they all pretty much stay the
same but it really depends on the meat
quality and uh you hit like you know
k-town and you know k-town and then
there's uh like sautel area in la they
got the the fire spots the real
authentic spots you know i haven't been
to the spa i mean i haven't eaten meat
in a long time but it's unfortunate
it was just like hey man you want to
cook it
why did i come here that's like
everything like you want me to oh yeah
right right right but i did that hibachi
was it called okay right right when they
they do the [ __ ] events and like
yeah that shit's tight it's cool it's
cool you're paying for a show too yeah
that's just cool and the korean barbie
stuff i've done that before but that's
what i'm like uh all right i'm good i'm
gonna leave but i haven't been to the
spots in so long yeah i see you guys do
my homies go there all the time they
know that they're like yeah we're not
gonna call you man because you know you
don't want to go man yeah it's fine
so that's your [ __ ] right there the what
do you call shama what do you call it
that shabu-shabu so that's where else
you're going besides those like that's
like one group right right i'm just
curious because i see you do all this i
never ask like where is this
there's um there's some places i don't
see around um like
north hollywood area like over the hill
you know what i mean because i live like
under the hill like in the cut in l.a
but you go over the hill a little bit
and then you get some good italian spots
with some good pasta they cook it like
in the wheel type [ __ ] i've seen that i
mean i've seen that i went to um
paseo el paseo okay okay i went there
with my homie the other day
it's pretty cool man
it's pretty cool i
see how like all these rich people that
you see in movies like oh that lady's
plastic looking because you don't you
don't see that when you see it in person
oh it's not just the movies yeah she's
eating food next to me this is crazy so
i went there the other day and i saw the
wheel like a big cheese wheel right
right yeah they're just sitting in a hot
pasta it's
pretty cool i will say it's pretty damn
cool man
you're doing all the stuff that you can
cook yourself or you do the hot stuff
you go to the italian spots i've just
seen you been
what i'm really asking i saw you eating
some [ __ ] with some flowers and like
some water what was this oh i think
you're talking about i went to a little
infused dinner is that what it was yeah
okay so the people at el blento put that
on for us and it was just like a little
private dinner in their facility we just
cooked it up they had a traveling chef
that does cannabis stuff and he'd had
like a seven course meal each one was
dipped with like a little bit of just
good stuff
and uh
yeah good medicated stuff but at the
like you didn't really taste that at all
it just really just seemed like a an
insane like seven course meal that if
like foods i've never even tried like
the combinations textures i was like
this is [ __ ] insane for sure that's
what i meant i saw the crate i mean it
looked like art yeah yeah it looked like
they placed it with with with plot with
a with yeah
it was crazy the first time i ever had
done like i mean like i get courses
sometimes or whatever like you know they
have something but
that's something like that like where
it's like art based like that you know
see and it's infused like yeah come on
there's some oh there's some spot vegan
spots like that that are yeah fine
dining right right and i look at it and
i'm like
i'm just gonna be hungry i haven't eaten
this yeah yes yeah i was hungry at the
end of it yeah i was just throwing too
because i was like man i'm just
wondering the more you eat the more yeah
exactly
so you've been in l.a for nine months
the last time we talked to you was brand
new brandon you've just been for eight
days
you stopped and left came to l.a how
what's your family
i always want to ask like
how did your family go all right yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here what was the
reaction after you left uh no i like as
i was leaving like i told him i was
leaving and everything i know because
they you stopped school correct right
right so you stopped school you left and
as you're here
are they pissed nah they're just you
know they're happy for me yeah
yeah yeah they're just uh just making
sure i'm not doing anything stupid you
know they're glad i'm not in texas
anymore it's the main thing they're like
they were just really scared for me to
get [ __ ] arrested or like do some you
know stupid [ __ ] because you know just
the cops out there sounding too friendly
with weed and everything so it was only
just a matter of time before i had to
head over here so
they're happy about it for sure maybe
not the exact like you know they're not
the we most weed friendly people ever
they tell me that i would rather be like
a doctor you know you should have been a
doctor like but at the same time it's
like but i still like love you and i
like we like what you're doing like i'm
glad that you are able to do what you do
cool man yeah so you do have the support
it's not like they shunned you and said
yeah get them all right right right no
no yeah oh sure they're real cool about
it
sorry
yo why aren't we smoking weed
i just looked up and went
what the [ __ ] is happening
that's all good sorry okay sorry that
was amazing dude so they they didn't
care yeah i mean
they probably cared but they weren't
really trying to like slow me down or
trying to like get you know what i mean
because some parents are like helicopter
parents are like no you can't do that at
all but what do your parents do
uh my mom is like a medical billy
and she's starting her own little um
she's starting so he's crazy so she's
always like done
um like she's always made like dope food
like that's just been her thing like
mama's touch kind of thing like just
insane like desserts is mainly the
mainly thing that's like cake balls and
like [ __ ] different little desserts
and i like uh oriental stuff too like
you know what i mean back in the hitting
into the culture little vietnamese stuff
like she's vietnamese oh okay yeah yeah
so getting a lot of like home-cooked
meals and [ __ ] like that like better
than the restaurants type stuff you know
i mean with the ingredients a little
touch
oh yeah 100 100
so
um she's real good at all that but
i've always been telling her like these
would be sick edibles and she's like no
no like i don't even want to like touch
that stuff
and i was like but there's this new
stuff like that maybe you know and i
mean you can get a little bit going and
it's legal in all these states and i've
been telling her about like delta aid
and the hhc and all that stuff and she's
she's on board like she's down it's been
taken years it's taken years of just
trying to tell her like this is like
this is gonna hit like these are
delicious by themselves you can sell
these by themselves but like you could
sell these extra hard if they got you
high
and then she's she's down like she's
we've been working on it i've been
trying to like we've been building this
brand for her in the past like a couple
months it's lit i'm super excited about
it
oh man that's cool man holy [ __ ] your
parents are not only supporting it now
she's like
she's like [ __ ] now that i see what's
really going on like yeah yeah because
she's almost like she was in like the
dare program influenced almost like damn
near as much too you know what i mean
type [ __ ] so like
shit's just she knows she i always had
that feeling like my family has that
stigma about it too it's like damn
you're like heroin like you don't even
want to [ __ ]
[Music]
but they know what we do right right
right but they're not gonna like they're
not gonna touch it but yeah they're
still gonna stay away as far as possible
from it for sure and my friend's mom
helps him make edibles too
which is kind of awesome that's awesome
oh [ __ ] really yeah
that's cool so um
your mom was a medical biller yeah yeah
so you just
school get good [ __ ] grades my mom's
in the medical field you can't really do
you have bro you have younger siblings i
have uh yeah i have three on their
shipping so i i was an only child for a
fat minute like growing up 100 and then
i got my first sibling when i was like
14.
oh yeah so i was in only two from your
mom mad dad had more kids when you were
14 and wait uh my mom had a uh i was uh
my mom was a single parent for a fat
minute oh sh she got a step dad and i
guess everything i gotta step dad type
[ __ ] you know what i mean oh [ __ ] yeah
there's that's the reason that that
[ __ ] is the reason i got caught
so
i mean oh the first time i no no we're
cool we're cool but
but the first time i ever got caught
smoking weed the only time was because
of him because my mom doesn't even know
what it smelled like she was like is he
vietnamese also no he's black he's a
black dude so he knew he's american yeah
oh so he knew the smell just by being in
america right right oh no way
it was just being my sister until i was
14 and that right when i turned 15 i had
my little brother yeah i wanted to show
you the picture it was like zendaya and
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
him and then my dad married a lady with
three kids and then had three kids okay
so it's just me and my sister tell us 15
then i have like eight siblings out of
nowhere it was
a change
it was a change christmas is like all
right make a checklist man make sure i
got every single one of you bulls
so how old are your uh younger siblings
uh they're a little older now i think
they're six five and two
so they're tiny
they're tiny so you're literally
standing there on christmas holding up
kids yeah they're they're the yeah they
always hang on to my legs and i gotta
like [ __ ] walk okay you're the way
older that's right
i'm 15 years older than my little
brother okay no i mean exactly exactly
exactly
i was born and my other sister is 16
uh
15 and my little brother's eight
so we have a huge we have a 20 [ __ ]
five year gauge difference almost it's
pretty interesting oh for everyone
wondering his little puppies right here
so if you're wondering what's that
little barking it's not marty
i'm actually
marty's just dmx
[ __ ]
so your family reacted great that's
[ __ ] awesome dude yeah yeah yeah i'm
really happy about that i'm glad it's a
little convincing for sure how'd your
stepdad what did it what was the
scenario where he found you though
because he's new coming into your life
right right right jesus no no not at all
so i like i uh okay so this is man it's
crazy story a little crazy story you
gotta strap in a little bit all right
so i'm like
17. just freshly started smoking we just
got my license too so i'm feeling good
confident you know and i mean just got a
girlfriend getting a little serious as
serious as high schoolers get and i'm
meeting their parents it's like a friday
night or something
yeah but it is friday after school too
so you know you're chilling with the
homies we go to the you know we're high
boxing or whatever the garage
and i'm really thinking
i'm like man i don't know if it's a good
idea to like smoke hot box right now
because what if i smell like weed later
and i'm like wait a minute i just go
home shower i'll be all right
so i'm smoking smoking and i say hey
guys homies are gonna go to the mall
they're like you want to come with us
i think about it i'm like
i guess i could air out here but i also
want to take a shower and like get ready
and stuff so like nah i'm good like i'll
see you guys go home
i go home
and walk through the door
and the front door is right by the
stairs my room's upstairs so usually i
can slip up and go right upstairs and
then just go right to my room too and i
can just get away with even if i smell
you know what i mean no one has to smell
you don't even have to say hi to anybody
i walk through the front door
boom my mom's right there a few feet
away first time ever she says oh i'm
glad that you're here i mean your
stepdad needs help moving the tv do you
think you can help him
i'm like yeah like let me just go change
real quick i gotta you know what i mean
i get
it's a bad excuse yeah it's horrible
excuse me she was like she looked at me
a little weird yeah these clothes
she looked at me over and she's like no
you won't get dirty or anything and i
was like all right like i already tried
[ __ ] it so i'm like maybe i don't smell
that bad so i walk in
she doesn't say anything i help move the
tv he doesn't say anything everything's
cool i think i get away with it i go all
the way upstairs and i'm like holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i take off my clothes i put it
in the hamper and everything
and here like a little
i'm like [ __ ]
and i open up the door
my mom's crying
she's like
are you doing drugs and i was like [ __ ]
and i was like
i'm just like i'm just smoking a little
weed and i guess
yeah yeah i just said it to her i just
said it to it
i was 17. so i was like it was like a
year from now and everything and i was
like you know what mom like i'm just
smoking weed like it's not even that bad
you know i'm not doing anything too
crazy
and she was just you know the typical
parent stuff like what did i do wrong
like how did it get to this and i'm like
no it's not like that like i just do
with my homies like we just like like
getting a little fake like i don't know
you know what i mean trying to explain
it in the best way that i can and she
just doesn't get it i'm like how did you
even know
she's like
and do you smell funny and your stepdad
said it smelled like weed
he's a straight edge type of dude yeah
yeah yeah oh he's a straight edge yeah
uh not not really he used to smoke weed
and [ __ ] back in the day but he was like
yeah yeah he said he just how long had
he been with your mom until that
happened
a few months wow
that's what i'm
what's up do you hate him after that or
not no not really it was just like
i didn't think he like snitched snitched
me out or anything but i was like damn
that's kind of [ __ ] up but i'm sure
she like because she said i smelled
funny so i'm sure she was just like she
would have asked her some [ __ ] anyway i
smelled like smoke at the very least she
thought i was smoking cigarettes i think
she said yeah i smoked a cigarette i'm
very sorry i was gambling
and then i was like [ __ ] playing
cards just moving
i'm 17 years old did he know that your
mom would be having a heart attack over
the weed uh i don't think so no he was
just like i think he was just answering
the question she was like what does he
smell like like what is he smelling like
he just says to you the next interaction
with you and him you got some weeds did
you guys both put your hands together
did you cross each other for sure for
sure it was a little it was a little
weird between us for a little bit but it
was just like i mean what a bad way to
start right i was like come on
especially if it was accidental you
accidentally snitch on the f
you're almost 18 at that point i mean
it's like right right i was i was just
close but
oh yeah anyway
but at first i got caught and then i
realized i got my phone taken away got
my keys away and i was like wait i gotta
[ __ ] go meet the parents
so i [ __ ]
stood up
my ex-girlfriend's parents i like that
you said x
because that wasn't gonna be a good
start anyway yeah for sure so yeah
oh no you just never showed up oh never
showed up couldn't contact her you know
what i mean got everything taken out
they would have pulled a high school
dope out the window
jogged my ferris bueller moment over
there
i don't think there's a way i could let
that happen
but that's just me and like my movie
brain like
damn the keys everything's gone step dad
this sounds like an 80s movie yeah yeah
i could escape that hoe and just did
something yeah you could you could have
made it if you really wanted to yeah but
it was like yeah it was x just a couple
reasons
what were you driving back down uh it
was my first car it was a c250 mercedes
it was a used first car yes yeah yeah
yeah see everyone yeah it was lit
because everyone was always like
everyone called me like spoiled and like
oh bro you got like the mercedes and
[ __ ] but they had like new like honda
accords and civics that were like 20.
25. yeah like 10 racks more and i was
like bro my like my car is like half the
price years like it's like mine's got
mine used and everything like a good
deal like sorry guys like i don't know
what you want me to say
yeah dude
what was your
did you grow up do you grow up with
money do you guys grow up poor [ __ ] you
guys are up
fine no i like decent my mom had to work
a lot for sure she was working like two
jobs and then my grandparents raised me
oh same one okay yeah in the same boat
so but we weren't like struggling i
wasn't going like hungry or anything and
i got christmas gifts and stuff but oh
is it a regular american kitchen right
right okay that's just something
yeah
nothing too over the top
all right
so i have a question here
i brought it up i mean i someone brought
something up to me the other day
i wonder if anybody else gets [ __ ] like
this have you ever read something about
yourself online that you're like yo when
the [ __ ] did this happen for sure what
is the craziest [ __ ] you've read about
yourself that you go
i never did that what the [ __ ]
because it's weird because you're just a
normal guy right right you're just
living your life yeah but you got to
remember that there's [ __ ] out
there that are writing wikipedias and
[ __ ] because they're such big fans yeah
and then people yeah i met him at the
mall he tried to punch me in the [ __ ]
face what is the craziest thing you've
heard about yourself online that you've
read uh i've had some really cool fan
experiences honestly nothing too crazy
but it was just a web page it might
still be like that but the main
it's like the famous birthdays page
since i got arrested
in a city at like a certain time on a
certain day for like something and i was
like i've never been like it was like a
colorado
in like 2019 and it was like for this i
was like i never that never happened to
me like what the [ __ ] and it's like if
you type in like aircon it's like the
third or fourth link that comes up see
that's the [ __ ] i'm talking about it's
like i've read [ __ ] about myself like
them like what yeah
are they [ __ ] with me yeah they have
to be just [ __ ] i send in a little
like edit and i was like this definitely
did not send it and read it that's what
i tried to do and it didn't change they
probably just didn't know the internet
because i didn't know you could like a
rebuttal
online stuff sometimes they do if it's a
cool little website i guess it's like is
this true like can you verify this or
whatever
the only things that really upset me
online would be to say my net worth i'm
like bro [ __ ] help me yeah like i
wish i wish
crazy i guess if i sold every single
little penny i had then maybe
other than that they think that you get
revenue
yeah yeah so they're like yeah the net
worth might for real where's the win
oh man for real oh yeah that's not right
oh no youtube doesn't pay far
so i heard i read some [ __ ] the other
day and i was like
i've never even i didn't i didn't never
met david dobrik he said i got [ __ ]
my youtube started off with david dobrik
like
isn't that the [ __ ] big ass youtuber
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm nervous like
seeing this
[ __ ] yeah so i read a whole article
about myself the other day
are you [ __ ] kidding me i don't think
that kid wants to hang out with some
ex-drug dealer
they're
i see you're an avid fan and i just
wanted to ask
i see you're in sports
i see you have
some opinions on sports so you're a fan
okay okay did you play sports growing up
yeah what did you play uh i did a couple
years of football from like fifth grade
to
ninth grade
linebacker uh corner why did i feel like
you were like the [ __ ] tallest i did
like in fifth grade i was a linebacker
because i was a little bigger than the
other kids and then like i was like i
got a little smaller yeah
smaller and faster yeah yeah no [ __ ]
that's i feel like that is the most
stressful [ __ ] position because
you're the only [ __ ] out there
that's either gonna get burned yeah get
[ __ ] out caught and either one is bad
yeah yeah so how was that corner i
always played [ __ ] lines so it was
never [ __ ] okay yeah yeah yeah
extravagant it was pretty fun the uh the
craziest i guess story that i have of
doing that is um damn i [ __ ] the kid
up and i didn't even really mean to
right so like i'm on the outside and
then there's no receiver on my side so
i'm playing like closer to the line you
know and then it's a pitch on my side so
like the running back's coming but the
fullback's coming like right for me so
i'm like well there's no chance of me
getting this running back like this
guy's right in front of me
so i'm just like [ __ ] it so i'm just
like you know what i mean lower man wins
kind of thing i just like go over low on
this fullback and i just hear like a big
and he's like oh [ __ ] and then he like
falls back
and he breaks his arm too like on the on
the fall back and he's just like they're
screaming on the phone like i've never
heard someone scream like this i'm in
eighth grade i'm like 13 i'm like
what the [ __ ] and the craziest thing was
like it was a fat run like he got like
70 yards on it so it was just like a cop
yeah and yeah i didn't do [ __ ] about it
i looked over and i was like damn they
got this so i just ran down the field
and like looked back and he was just
screaming still in the field and i was
like what did you break just beside his
arm i was like i guess like like real
like when like right for his like you
know what i mean i went like real low
you know he was a big kid
yeah
oh that shit's illegal sir
that is illegal
for that reason
damn he broke his leg and arm yeah on
the way down he hates [ __ ] up he was
[ __ ] up for sure oh hey
but no dog ate his homework
my dog literally ate my homework party
i love you for that
so real quick for everyone driving i
have some paperwork my my notes
right here and um
the puppy just ate them i looked down
marty's just doing this first person
ever down to actually to actually get my
homework eaten by the dog dog ate my
homework all right that was an organic
organic bart simpson moment i appreciate
i'm not even mad at it it's fine just i
don't want him to get sick
hey
don't do that all right yeah come on
buddy so you broke this this young boy's
arm and leg in eighth grade yes did you
was that team like in your town or was
it a traveling uh it was all in town so
you had to see this kid again eventually
i don't think so i hope not i don't know
i think you recognize me i don't know he
recognized your brother
you think the kid during summer didn't
get
thinking about it the whole time that
[ __ ] yes with a broken arm and
leg yeah he remembers you man and now he
sees the videos like he doesn't even
want to bring it up because some of his
friends watch or [ __ ] i bet and go i
don't even want to tell you guys i don't
even want to tell you guys you're going
to be on his side you guys are his fans
you got to say like there's nothing he
could say like well he did a better job
but also he did block you yeah yeah i
mean it was just yeah he did block you
yeah did you guys win that game i'm
pretty sure yeah i don't know we were
pretty ass
you sucked yeah yeah
okay so you played for a couple years of
football yeah did you play any other
sports track after i played football i
did track are you fast as hell i did
jumping i'll say you're pretty tall bro
i feel like you're just lengthy yeah you
could jump you did high jump i did a
little bit of high jump but it was maybe
triple jumping long jump triple jump
doesn't work in my brain it's like yo
hyper stand your knee [ __ ] your leg up
jump again
it doesn't make sense
yeah i've seen my homies do but they're
all [ __ ] gangly and tall guys i just
envisioned the aircon push trees collab
where he's running with the [ __ ] big
joint yeah
[Music]
i mean i really watch but i don't really
watch the winter olympics as much right
right but i do like all the shame
yeah they're just like different [ __ ]
stuff
yo i almost did it again marty
turn the light to mike yep almost did it
again
[ __ ] pookie over here
sorry my bad so
sports you did play sports you did track
and field were you any good at dragon
field uh i was pretty decent at it yeah
i was i was placing a couple of edit
meets and stuff yeah but i wasn't going
to like the regional shits or anything
like that you know what i mean i wasn't
tracked
honestly i was the only like asian kid
ever that i was always doing that [ __ ]
you know what i mean were you smoking
before the meats and [ __ ] or not yet
not yet not yet that was really that
when i started smoking heavily that's
when i just stopped doing sports
yeah that wasn't on the show that was me
yeah that's a theme on the show
everybody i just really started smoking
a lot and you know i just stopped i
stopped playing football because i had a
dazed and confused moment with my coach
you ever seen oh yes bro you wanted me
to cut my [ __ ] hair
why because he said only women have long
hair
and our number one wide receiver the kid
with the biggest afro ever he was always
on him about cutting his [ __ ] hair
off
i mean the kid had a [ __ ] full afro
you're gonna have to do this what's the
[ __ ]
he's just a [ __ ]
he's just a [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
crew cut probably got punked when he was
younger but now he's like i've seen the
kid rep 450 the coach though like like
it's nothing yeah since i also don't
want to fight you
but also i [ __ ] don't like it man
you're a [ __ ] why do you want me to
come in here
so i stopped playing sports because of
that and i was doing drugs and then i
started selling drugs but i just i
wanted to ask too busy i was too busy
not doing productive things
so i wanted to ask
i see you
you're avid sports fan
you're also a saints fan yes okay how
did that happen living in [ __ ] texas
because i'm a packers fan living in
california nice so i get i'm sure you
get [ __ ] on for it yeah yeah some people
ask that all the time but the first
people that i started watching football
with were um like people on [ __ ] xbox
i was like eight or nine or something
just playing xbox and then the people in
my party were like yo eric like put on
the game i was like what game like i
don't even know what y'all are talking
about and they were saints fans so i was
just watching like saints fans like on
xbox live with these [ __ ] random
people because you didn't have a
hometown team right nah and i was in san
antonio and then i hated [ __ ] cowboys
fans drew a breeze for you your whole
life yeah yeah yeah cause you're younger
than me but i was like when you're not
droopy's just retired you watched your
whole life with your friends right drew
brees was like the whole like every
desire to every entire years yeah tim
duncan the man who and chad oh yeah that
oh yeah i was a big spurs fan for sure
but that we didn't have a football team
and then i just didn't really like the
cowboys fans they're real annoying so
with drew brees being gone
how do you feel
sports is one thing because marty's a
bills fan they got [ __ ] on for the for
his whole life the bills are looking
good bill's looking good they just keep
[ __ ] let it slip
packers i'm lucky that brett favre
rodgers my whole existence of life he
might be back
yes so i'm in the boat with you guys
coming up because the saints were
[ __ ] the [ __ ] my mom's a saints fan
and a bears fan so i mean the saints are
great yeah
that [ __ ] what's his name the
backup uh hill i have jason hill
he's an all-in-one he's a receiver a
[ __ ] quarterback and a running back
he's a badass
what what's the future for the saints
because i've seen you go off
i've seen you have some opinions about
sports yeah and this one's like calling
out owners like the [ __ ] owner of a
bubble yo you watch sports
i don't watch sports like that
yeah [ __ ] uh [ __ ] i think we're gonna
just re-sign jameis hopefully give him
another shot jameis winston our
quarterback
for the season
yeah yeah i thought it was the hill dude
uh at the end of the season because
james winston got hurt but we were
looking good with james winston we were
like four and one or something we beat
the packers
it's a good name it's all good
all good do you want another joy do you
want to light up uh
oh i'm like
oh i'm down the ladder i'll light it
i'll light it up after that i'll smoke
that with you don't try it okay
so saints i just wanted to ask you about
sports man because i see you also you're
you're you're brave man
this man has a twitter following and
follows no one
only the president's allowed to do [ __ ]
like that man
how do you find your news if you're not
following people i have like another
account that i just like i guess my
personal account so you just see stuff
like that right that i follow because i
always i'm not getting a twitter man i'm
always i have to follow people to see
stuff right yeah i literally find
something and then i'm like i go over to
the other account and then talk about
it's [ __ ] like twitter seems like the
friendliest place for you guys but it's
like nobody gives a [ __ ] right right it
looks great i love it twitter is cool it
is cool it's uncensored you can't just
what i'm saying but it's like you just
say i see like more like titties and
weed and like oh me and rosie talk about
it all the time because we have some we
have a couple of friends that do are
like porn star chicks all right so we
don't follow him on twitter and i'll be
in public and the [ __ ] they like yeah i
gotta do this and i'll probably just do
this oh i'm getting off the hat people
are gonna think i'm a [ __ ] creep
rosie all the time i've seen her do this
in public
i'm like oh you're on twitter [ __ ] dude
let me exit out of twitter and go get in
the car twitter's one of those it's
[ __ ] crazy because whatever they like
you see
whatever they comment you see anyone
that you have that's why you'd want to
have a private program
you're smart
zeke is i'm telling you mean rosie bulgo
we can't even open twitter in public
people think we're [ __ ]
creeps
so it's crazy that's why i'm like yo
only the president [ __ ] is
allowed to follow no one
cause he knows that [ __ ] trick that's
a good trick that's a good trick it's
dangerous out there but then i would
never receive people's stuff yeah that's
why you gotta be on like the main
account all the time
exactly exactly so that was one of my
questions um
so
what do you think back to what i was
saying what do you think the future is
for the saints what's going on what what
do you think do you think you're gonna
have a run of like a couple years of
being off i'm a saints fan i think so i
think i think we're gonna have a couple
years left if it depends if jameis is
you know just as good if our defense can
keep up i think we'll just still be in
the playoff hunt it's got to be the
right like opponents you know
we've got to be at the right time right
right perfect thing i don't think
they're good enough they're going to be
good enough to be like that team that
just stomps everyone but like that that
49ers team that just like kind of sneaks
in you know and i mean and like
that somehow
[ __ ] there's a good way to put it
because i don't know how the [ __ ] the
niners made it this year yeah deep they
made it they beat the team they they
made it to the wait almost in the super
bowl
i was shocked yeah i felt rigged for
sure nfl is raped 100
do you think the nfl's rigged it's
scripted as [ __ ] i don't know enough to
even [ __ ] speak wwf now okay yeah i
mean i've heard that it is it's [ __ ]
up yeah and there's too many clips i've
seen and go oh you [ __ ]
you could see the tide changes in like
people like
you let that go you couldn't tackle him
you're a lion
but they're getting paid bro yeah
they're getting paid millions what's a
50k bonus you can make in one play by
going hey man when you make a cut just
slip and don't get that first
perfect they're probably at the end
going um i got seven
calls okay you guys owe me thirty two
thousand now you gotta be like you guys
owe me this i just watched any given
sunday again oh protein fox it's a wild
man in that one
same exact scenario right that happened
in that movie right yeah with a is i
can't isn't gene hackman do you watch
every any given sunday no it's a good
ass [ __ ] football movie camera diaz
you got [ __ ] it's a blockbuster of a
football movie jamie foxx is like oh
cool jay and cherry is is ella cool j2
excel yeah like rudy level it's a good
movie oh no rudy no not really a whole
different one
different different kind of ones what is
it shawn aston
[ __ ] from stranger things now
it's rude jam you know people for real
that's who that is that's who it is
they're full for [ __ ] 50 first dates
so next question since you've moved here
i know the answer's going to be yes but
i want to know what it is
have you seen yourself just get more
opportunities since you've been yeah
easily for sure they're just like the
doors are just like open you know
i feel like before you would have to
like almost scavenge for them
like really dig through it you know what
i mean yeah really each grind for it but
now i have to like
grind through all of them for the good
ones type [ __ ] you know what i mean like
it's it's like a cool feeling
yeah yeah it's like a whole little flip
it's like yo i don't have enough
customers to oh [ __ ] who do i want to
work with yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly
that's almost how it feels like because
from you if you took every single thing
that people threw at you you'd be
posting 60 videos a month yes exactly
100
right right so when people go like fam
man all you do is sponsor videos like no
no no if you really wanted to know
it would be crazy if all i did was
sponsored videos then you would 100 now
but yeah you're the same way like
grinding on like a second channel or
getting these other avenues
you know what i mean like what is your
second channel uh more con and more
iricon
and it's a car channel we've been
running up in numbers it's been pretty
cool holy cars yeah only card channels
good [ __ ] no smoke or anything and um
it's been cool it's been cool the growth
has been cool uh we just hit 50k
good [ __ ] yes i'm trying to get my
[ __ ] plaque because they never gave
me my plaque man i got one for my second
channel
when i got when we got ours
whoa this is what it's like being a
the other communities are crazy have you
ever noticed like other communities are
almost like more hostile or something
dude we communities are cool you know
they're true people are violent yeah and
internet comments like internet comments
are [ __ ] insane if it's not in the
weekend the wii community is about 96
percent cool right right and then you
get like
you don't even smoke yeah you get some
people that are 14 of this stupid [ __ ]
my dad said
your dad's a tweaker you smoke a mess
shut the [ __ ] up
but in the car community in the
weightlifting community in the makeup
community you'll get a girl dedicated to
my grandmother [ __ ] your grandma in the
comments like i hope she [ __ ] dies
like she is dead it's a dedication
dude people are hostile so you're
getting all these people in your car
crazy that car sucks it's not even six
million dollars yeah yeah or not even
that they'll go after like they'll be
like what the [ __ ] is this little asian
kid doing in this whip like they'll be
like oh oh oh yeah yeah don't be like he
doesn't even drive it right right i
would drive it so much better though
they're like then go buy one
[ __ ] yeah i get that a lot it's
a [ __ ] fat mexican piece of [ __ ]
being here like
jesus
look at [ __ ] i get that a lot [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] being i get that all the
time like damn dude
yeah on my second channel yeah yeah on
the second channel let's see all family
friendly and it's like yo youtube
you shit's backwards you're letting all
this hatred on the family friendly but
let the nice stuff when we don't get
paid
it's crazy
that's weird
i wasn't even aware of that i would
never pay for
yeah it's insane it's insane i saw your
what was it uh
like cruise through like what was it
midnight drive or some [ __ ] yeah yeah
post on his second channel it looks like
if you're any other state you're anybody
that likes cars that's the [ __ ]
direction you guys are hitting i think
yeah yeah yeah because like it's like
gta type [ __ ] exactly like it's exactly
like hey and i always get those comments
they're like eric's living that gta life
and i'm like i'm just kind of driving
down the boulevard but like yeah yeah
from the gta right there stay building
exactly yeah yeah it's weird going to
vanessa santa monica like oh it's too
much for me right i've shot
[ __ ] in the game
right here we did a stash there the
other day nice and in santa monica and i
put it in this part of the stairs up by
the pier yeah so come get it and
somebody dm'd us them getting
the same exact spot in gta like where's
it at that was it's pretty good that was
pretty good you [ __ ]
the exact same spot that i posted
dude it goes hard they go hard yeah for
sure bro they see that they made a
little tweet and they're working on the
sixth one yeah
yeah crazy it's coming i hope it's
[ __ ] it's gone
take a minute can we crack my best idea
of all time real quick see if people
like it put that out there uh
yes because we had franklin on the other
day on here the other day that's awesome
and i was thinking about something like
this the other day then right before you
got here marty had this idea go we go
ahead and take all the audios from
thomas's favorite famous story time
series
all these existing episodes there's got
to be what [ __ ] how many of them
200
we take all the audio we license it to
rockstar and we get the story time
channel on gta 6 when you're driving
around you can just be listening to the
story times as one of the channels be
the talk radio channel yeah i wonder if
there's like a
oh there'll be a podcast section
they have to be the exact podcast you
the crazy [ __ ] talking on the radio
that would be i told rosie hey what if i
told him like yo let me be laszlo i'll
be the [ __ ] that's talking on
the radio the whole time and then marty
brought that up that is epic yeah that's
the metaverse [ __ ] mm-hmm we need that
that's the meta version i saw on your uh
stream that you're still doing in nfts
oh yeah what are you doing what are you
doing what do you think what are you
investing in
i'm just buying like these little art
projects that are like hyped up you know
what i mean buying and selling them and
just seeing which there's like there's
probably like a dozen projects that drop
a day and it's like probably one or two
of them are probably worth anything and
then probably won't be worth anything in
like a week so like you just gotta find
there's like probably one a month that's
going to be worth like
a lot a lot of love that's gonna like go
crazy crazy but you really just it's
just really just like flipping
it's almost like flipping penny stocks
or some [ __ ] almost like you're just
digging through the mud like flipping
for double three times sometimes like
sometimes they're gonna loss here you
can like flip it for this you know it's
just it's kind of fun it's like
literally just like trading cards or
something like that right i told my
friends it's pokemon cards yeah yeah
yeah and i think it has a lot more
utility in the future but i could i
right now as it stands like i i can see
why people like hate on that [ __ ]
because i mean it's a little price
barrier to get into it i suppose and
then
it's not as much as people think it is
but i think nfcs have a huge future for
sure and everyone like all these
companies know about it and everything
and you know what i mean like it's it's
gonna be the future but
i think right now it's just in a really
really early stage where it's just these
it's like trading cards right now like
that's just glorified trading cards
right now but it's gonna be cool in the
future am i missing something because i
hear people say about like environmental
[ __ ] related yeah
what is that please explain what the
[ __ ] does that mean
so there's like two different ways to
verify all of the information that is
like available on the blockchain
and one of the ways is
slightly like harmful into the
environment they're like they're blowing
it up to be honest with you but there
are cases where like
like mining all this crypto definitely
isn't good for the environment because
it's like running all this electricity
and everything you know what i mean like
there's
you know what i mean but the electricity
is what they're worried about yeah yeah
it's like a big um because to prove that
this information is real it's just like
it takes a lot of power electricity is
already there right it's already going
exactly like it's already all going but
they're just finding something like
complain about it but they're already
working on yeah and they're already
working on something to like just like
like i said there's two different ways
the first one does take a lot of like
more electricity and a lot more power
but the second way is like very clean
very efficient and it's even faster okay
and that's like what it's working
towards you know what i mean something
that's child labor happening somewhere
over there no no no no no no i don't
know i was thinking oils and getting
helped from the ground no what are they
talking about
it's just like every trade you make like
it's like turning on a microwave for 30
seconds or something and it's like [ __ ]
you that [ __ ] happens anyway like you
know what i mean but that's their excuse
and honestly maybe it maybe it is good
electricity right right there's a
hundred things that they probably do
that are more harmful but yeah that's
i mean i guess if you want to say it's a
valid complaint like yeah it's gonna use
this it uses too much electricity and
it's gonna work towards using less but
it's nowhere near as like harmful into
the environment as people they're
basically saying
while i'm using the internet on my phone
to tell you that you're bad for the
environment i'm also being bad for the
environment by taking away from the
bandwidth that they have to use more
energy because i'm on the bandwidth
correct
right so they're contributing at the
same time by telling you that you're
[ __ ] up yeah driving a car for like a
couple of miles probably [ __ ] up
yeah our cars use a lot of [ __ ] gas
a lot i understand the car thing for
sure electric cars do scare me i don't
really they scare because it's like yo
turn off the electricity in l.a like no
one's car works that's fine
only the old dudes and chevelles and
impalas are walking are driving around
town like that'd be it we all be [ __ ]
i'm good good in the electric car for
now
um
oh my god i can believe oh nfts so since
the last time i still
my friends do it heavily but last time
you're the first person to kind of
explain it to me that my friend is
heavily heavily and empty does the board
ape things yeah yeah all the crazy
investments and [ __ ]
and i see it and every day he has a huge
screen in this and we're always every
time i go there dabbing it's just a huge
screen like this and he's just looking
at all the [ __ ] buying and doing this
and typing in the little
number to the thing rarity seeing like
and he's all i don't know what am i so
how much did you buy for how much you
sell for it's all you [ __ ] about because
i don't get it yeah yeah it's like well
the utility on this is very rare look at
this blah blah blah so you made four
hundred thousand dollars you just say
that [ __ ]
because i'm like no i don't care about
the utility the rareness like nobody's
mutated like
that's kind of cool also just catch me
out
i don't want because they they don't get
their money back they just put it into
the next project right so they're making
money but they're it's like i feel like
it's a gamble yeah i think it means like
letting it ride
yeah yeah yeah it's like as it stands
right now like yeah just like
collectible cards or anything else as a
gamble it's it's the same way
yeah unless they have cool utilities
yeah yeah there's definitely some with
cool utilities that are
that people are trying to implement
because that's like the future of it
like having nfts for a lot of [ __ ] is
going to be the future because another
thing that people say like another
argument against it is like
everything that we do right now is
already possible we don't need nfts
anymore right we don't need nft because
everything you know we already do it but
like that's the line that's the same
argument with like we don't need itunes
because we already have limewire like
why do we need that you know why where
do we need to put it why do we need
facebook if we already have friends
during space it's like saying why do we
need condoms we have herpes
that's like yo it makes it better
yeah yeah you're right like there's like
yeah there's influence there's some
somewhat of a basis of what it can be
but like
every single company that's like
i feel like every single billion dollar
company is working towards it like have
you seen like nike and then like
adidas i hope you bought all that [ __ ]
yeah for sure and then
dropped yeah marvel is working everybody
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing like
yeah for sure like if you gotta you just
gotta move where the money's moving and
you see all these people that see the
future of nfts and the utility of nfts
and what they can be it's gonna be cool
it's gonna be cool because it's
like you can just do a lot more [ __ ]
with that i think the biggest thing was
like that trading card aspect would just
be elevated to like everything like if
you have
a [ __ ] ticket to the rams game and
then i have a ticket to like this
[ __ ] music concert like you want to
trade and you just swap it instantly and
you don't have to do anything else you
know what i mean like you were saying
contracts yeah instead of having this
much paperwork yeah [ __ ] boom file
yeah yeah quickly i like that or they
were saying albums songs
purchasing use bam nft got it yeah yeah
and the big thing with the picture right
yeah big thing with artists as well if
you want to sell like your art like if
someone like the person who painted this
wanted to paint another one and one off
and just digitize it sell it as an nft
let's say they sell the first one for
like a thousand dollars and then it
becomes really really rare and they the
next person that person sells it for ten
thousand dollars normally
the artist doesn't get any sale of that
secondary money like as it stands right
now like it's it's impossible like yeah
you just can't do that but with nfts you
can set a creator royalty so you get how
a certain percentage of every single
sale that that nft has on forever so
that's like that's huge that's like game
changing that's like that's the
secondary sale my friend explained that
to me right mind-blowing it's it's it's
gonna change everything like it's gonna
change like that's how nike's gonna
implement it because they're not getting
any cut at this secondary sales like of
the stockx and this goat [ __ ] nike wants
a [ __ ] kind of that's crazy
they disapprove your nft or can you
upload is everything approved that's the
right file format um so
yeah you can upload pretty much anything
as an nfd can be a gif or a music file
or like anything it's just really binds
it nft is just like um it's really just
like the contract behind it so but they
don't like censor it at all
no no no i'm certain it kind of depends
there's certain marketplaces it's um you
can just list the nft and it holds it in
your wallet
but you need to list it onto a
marketplace so where people are able to
buy that so there's a whole bunch of
different marketplaces open c is the
biggest one and they're already going
they're like
under like controversy and fire because
they're not like truly decentralized
it's still a company at the end of the
day so they're able to like private some
listings or like halt sales or something
like this so like people are working to
build these platforms right right people
are working to build these platforms
that are like completely decentralized
like
not controlled by anybody but that's
also crazy too like the whole concept of
just like no authority at all like if
something were to get stolen because
that's a big thing about nfts oh my god
getting scammed and everything like
there's no guy lost his whole right you
can't hit like [ __ ] yeah you can't hit
up like
yep exactly you can't hit up anybody
he's got cops the wild wild west out
here man you stole your [ __ ] they stole
your [ __ ] right so one really good
hacker could [ __ ] up this entire earth's
energy one guy
um so that's another thing with openc
they were going through this little
controversy and um
some they were migrating all listings to
a new network or some [ __ ] but
um some guy found a way to manipulate
that contract and get into people's
wallets and he was draining people's
[ __ ] one by one just like and people in
the it's all public right the the
blockchain interview you can see it
people were refreshing and watching this
guy steal people's [ __ ] one by one and
they couldn't do anything about it and
people were like yo like and people are
just like emailing up and see like
twitter like what the [ __ ] are you doing
like can you fix this and they're like
we don't even know what's going on right
now and they're just refreshing
refreshing like he's taking hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars into crazy [ __ ] did he catch him
oh of course not of course they didn't
catch him he's chilling right now
yo it's probably a kid a hundred percent
you know how many kids out here just
smarter than everyone yeah being a kid
right now with the information
you're did you watch dr dexter's
laboratory oh
yes sir remember the episode where he's
like i want the potion that or the
chip that makes me have every knowledge
in the entire universe and his head gets
too huge
that's some of these kids right now yeah
all right they're
texas um
all right well nfts i just want to talk
is this the first time the first time
you came here we talked about it it's
been nine months and since then all i've
seen is it explode
exactly what you said is exactly what's
happening now watch these big companies
like nike is going to be in this and
everything is exactly what's happening
yeah so yeah good call you're you're on
camera calling it all right
um
so here we go i pulled a couple quick
fan questions oh go go go fan questions
go for it we haven't done that mid
episode yet
you just pulled them right now yeah i'll
[ __ ] run it
we got three of them
sprinting good [ __ ] go
best drink for cottonmouth
coming in from xr ryan xr
okay all right let's go ryan
um damn if you're gonna be born it's
gonna be water just like all day ice
cold water like wow that's all i'd ever
say yeah water yeah wow that's really
surprising for sure what else you i mean
yeah no i hear you [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
going spread it i'm sorry
yes yes that's great
carbonated though and it's like it
drains you after a basketball game
drinking a sprite is awesome but about
16 seconds later you're gonna
water
[ __ ] throw up kobe bryant made it
look so [ __ ] cool but yeah it doesn't
work
are you picky about your water though
like as far as oh you seem like you got
a brand oh yeah are you uh are you a
watcher if i'm thirsty
they have so many spots it's too easy
not to have don't drink the purified
water we learned that on them oh okay
okay yeah don't you purify water don't
you distilled water
yeah i've been trying a lot of people
especially out here been trying to put
me on the new water game is that is that
the la thing quality the water here's
trash
it's so bad here that makes sense the ph
or what was it the ph level i can't
remember what it was the parts per
million ppm we tested it at my first
apartment and rosie was looked it up on
a little bit
yeah we bought the little ph tester we
did the tap water we looked it up on
google and what the safe the safe number
is it's like 60 or some [ __ ] ours is 630
something i remember going like over six
something
and we were drinking that [ __ ] it's
before we realized what the [ __ ] we were
doing yeah dude the water out here is
toxic don't drink this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
don't
all right this is out so what's up
what's up with these got some nice
little
new anova blunts that i came out with
man collaboration with oblento okay so
tell us right now for everyone that just
popped in and goes who is this eric guy
i've never seen him before or maybe
their fans just haven't seen it all
anova go into that one that's your
company yes i know this is my company
give us the breakdown uh i would say the
easiest way to explain it would be like
like a marketplace
i also want to say i would compare it to
like a sound cloud for like certain
artists type [ __ ] but that's like a
weird way to put it no not sound
like a marketplace
yeah yeah like an ebay so um
i would compare here's the because i'm
so weak the easiest way to compare the
glass market would be to like the music
industry type [ __ ] because there's a
couple artists that run the game and
then there's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of artists that don't really
have like ace you know what i mean that
big of a following they're making glass
they're just trying to make ends meet or
they're making dope dope art and then no
one's really seeing it you know what i
mean so my platform anova is a weekly
based drop thing we collaborate with
artists around the country that are just
not really being seen we drop a kind of
like space
themed like that's kind of like the
theme purple like spacey
we use a lot of crushed opal and all the
glass from the artists that we have and
we just highlight different artists
every single week and give them you know
what i mean a little check a little
something they gotta check we get um
they get more exposure the people get
dope glass at a dope price um and you
don't have to go to a shop for it or
anything it's shipped right to your door
and it's just like a kind of like a
win-win-win for everybody you know what
i mean so when is the weekly
yeah every single monday at 4 20 p.m
specifically
every monday at 4 20 basically yeah do
you when do you tell everybody what the
new drop is uh usually that friday so
they have the whole weekend to get ready
and yeah okay so what's the instagram
anova.ig anova.ig and what's the website
uh novasmoke.com anovasmoke.com
all right anovasmoke.com and anova.ig so
basically
if you go there on monday it's not is it
a raffle is it it's just a first come
first service oh [ __ ] so it's like a
supreme drop yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
it's a limited edition sometimes we got
to just make sure you're [ __ ] you
know
i mean it's good yeah but it's like it
kind of feels
okay so you do them every monday at 4 20
and you uh you announce the artist on
friday yeah so
from that now you're collaborating with
el blunto and al bunto is a legal uh
hemp blunt yeah a legal hemp blunt here
in california um they reached out and
they're like yo do you want to have a
little you know the first one they had
you want to put your face on a blunt and
that's already like a dream come true
like what do you mean where is it going
to be so it's going to be sold in all
dispensaries like come on bro like
already i want that [ __ ] what did you
put in it what's strange our first
strain was a
my favorite strange tropicana cookies so
oh is it yeah yeah it's almost like a
forbidden fruit yeah 100 so i love that
[ __ ] so that was our first one and then
this one is gmo which has been my
favorite gmo for the past like year it's
not popping off i saw what else is in
this a little bit of extra it's also gmo
and it's ice water hash which is a
little weird that [ __ ] it's that [ __ ]
it's that all right and a glass tip are
these like what
two and a half grams let's say that
three grams
two one point two and five there we go
they just carry their weight yeah yeah
not two grams yeah so all the butt is
hand broken up uh it's not going to
grind up yeah not grind it up yeah i
just noticed that right do that you can
see like the lumps they're all different
i went there yeah and i saw everybody
like uh just doing like a [ __ ]
i was looking for someone to do it for a
while and i saw these companies using
the machine like
they shake all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
shake and it's just like this is
different there's no love in it you know
what i mean but this is like hand
actually hand roll type [ __ ] there's a
big facility i love the people behind it
they're cool as [ __ ] you know yeah we
talked about it earlier yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's cool like
um my homie oh remember charlie from
well he used to work yeah yeah yeah yeah
well his uh we have a company we're
starting right with another guy named
brett with his greater holdings they do
all the cannabis marketing right right
he brought me there yeah and when i went
in there i'm like yo you guys are really
sitting here with 40 people deep rolling
blunts
throwing blunts blind after blunt with
the little glue [ __ ] they're using
it was pretty [ __ ] cool to see
it's like when you see movies and fools
of chopping coke
it's all scary
and
yeah yeah it's just people just
smoking rolling blunts with headphones
and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] cool actually
so el blunt is this sold in all shops
too oh yeah yeah over 200 license
dispensaries across california
anova so you have your own branded like
i said earlier
this was a great way to
get your [ __ ] more expo because eric
khan your name is already there right
people are already going to go oh good
[ __ ] yeah but once they start this being
synonymous to you yeah then they're like
that's when we start monitoring
yeah and at the same time i almost want
to like have the brand separate from my
entity like i like like everyone knows
like there's dope companies yeah that
don't really you know i mean he's like
yeah yeah like my favorite company is
probably kith and there's like that [ __ ]
yeah yeah kid's my favorite company and
like a lot of people rock it they don't
know ronnie figgs behind it but i like i
love ryan
ronnie figg is the like owner and ceo of
kith and he runs it and everything he's
really like tapped into the culture and
the fans and everything in the community
it's super dope but even if you don't
know who ronnie figgis like you still
[ __ ] with kids you know i mean there's a
hundred you know most people do that so
same thing with like supreme and all
these like high brands like so that's
exactly what i want like a nova to be
like people want to [ __ ] with the nova
without necessarily knowing who i am or
that's the only way it works because
i've said it many times it's uh
people may like you and they'll support
you just because they like you
people that don't know you or maybe they
don't are not a fan or they maybe they
don't like you if they can go no i
really [ __ ] like this and not know
it's you and just know it's a good
product
then that's when you kind of win the
whole crowd right because it's not your
[ __ ] face right here saying oh
garrett connor nova blunt yeah yeah yeah
yeah the clothing that i try to run it's
not like
it's super on your face like air con has
it or like or even super in your face
like i smoke weed
[Music]
i always i for push trees my thing is
[ __ ] over the top picture crazy yeah
it's awesome
when you're diving up my favorite one is
when he's surfing on the dab yeah it's
just like wait what the [ __ ] is that so
it is loud but there's also like [ __ ]
like the the darkness
yeah i just try to make it like like
pictures but right it's not my face yeah
yeah if it's gonna be loud it has to be
creative yeah i guess it can't be wacky
are new shits like this like just very
like branded just quick quick [ __ ] nice
nice nice
with this right with this right here uh
oh you're saying trying to separate it
that's why
we may push trees and it's not just say
like
dope zola shirts yeah yeah yeah
but it's more like i'm not just trying
to rock a shirt this is air con on it
i'm trying to say dope is your life you
have to separate it for it to grow and
one day maybe you don't want to be like
doing videos all [ __ ] days maybe you
don't exactly yeah and you still have
your business side you built for
yourself everything
because people kill for a following
right companies pay for a following
you can't pay for an organic following
for sure we've said it many times you
can't pay for what you've built you
can't pay for what we've built because
it's years and years of being yeah yeah
people coming up to you and everything
like you can't buy that you can't you
can't yeah you can't buy it man yeah
[ __ ] it it's impossible i mean companies
try and that's why they do they they
paid lebron james they're like yo no you
be our guy right you're sprite now
that's why they do that because they
need that [ __ ] because there's people
that connect with people and your [ __ ]
is very
i always when martin's like when we
first brought you up it's like eric
carter keep popping up in the [ __ ]
comments what was erica as a youtuber
right like yeah man this is how i
explain it it's like
having your friend in the car and you
guys are having a conversation
right because the way you do your videos
it's like right you're right [ __ ]
here yeah yeah yeah so it's like you're
just talking to your [ __ ] home so
that's why i think you've built such a
strong following and then yeah then you
switch and then you have some vlogs and
you mess it up but i think your strong
thing that people think of is they see
the picture yeah yeah of you you got to
see that they see you
just you know i mean that that's what
people come and like remember in their
head like right now your vlogs are
[ __ ] shake dan that review was tight
but they were like there for like you
right right it wasn't like a cool review
at first it was just you because you did
it when you were what started with like
seven yeah 17 i started making you
weren't even 18 started doing this [ __ ]
in an illegal ass state
first video was dropping acid
that was your first video with your face
showing yep
using my name crazy
was this before or after your stepdad
got your hat before or it was after it
was after oh you just went all crazy
after that caught me mom i'm doing asses
on the internet now oh
[ __ ] nothing
did you find out about your youtube yeah
years later though because thankfully it
was already popping enough so it was
like because um
it was actually
damn this is nuts so she
she actually asked like around junior
year
around like ended senior year because i
was still living with my parents my
first year at college and she was like
so what are you doing for like work
because you're not even like you know
what i mean you're not doing job or
anything and i was like oh i'm just um
like doing the youtube thing
because i did youtube in high school and
she was like oh i just like the video
games and stuff and i'm like yeah i'm
just like streaming playing video games
and stuff and she was like oh okay okay
cool well you're making money yeah yeah
as long as you're chilling you know
whatever she honestly preferred because
i didn't have to like leave the [ __ ]
house you know and i mean she loved it
um and then
my cousin watches my videos like ireland
he's super chilly he's like not letting
go
um did you say an irl yeah yeah you're a
[ __ ] gamer because my homie ratchman
be like irl bro i'm like
in real life is that what you're saying
to me oh i didn't know real life
because he's he's in the uh gta role
play all day he's building a server yeah
yeah that's it so he's like not full irl
i was with that fool the other day i'm
like yo
you guys are computers these tools are
[ __ ] irl they switch back
so when you say i'm like wait is that
what you just said
my homie's been getting me on that i'm
like wow
yeah yeah
he's not letting any family know or
anything but one time he left it his
computer opened all my videos
his mom sees me smoking weed on the
internet tells my entire family i get a
text from my mom and it was like it was
like a it when it rains it pours kind of
day i just got in a [ __ ] accident
like a car accident and i'm literally
getting my car like inspected and
everything like waiting for the cops to
come and she and i get the text i get
the text and i'm like there's no way
there's no [ __ ] way this is happening
right now so i get this long text and
anytime you get a paragraph text like i
didn't even like i opened it and it was
like when i was like oh
like what did i do what i do
and it was like
your grandma saw your youtube channel oh
no and i think them one of the most
recent videos i posted it was a q a and
it was like what drugs i've done or
something like that and she was like
what kind of drugs are you doing or like
what are you doing online and all this
and i was like
it's worse than the only fans he's damn
neat it was worse than him
i'm just slinging some dick pics
oh my god yeah for real it's really hot
never mind but now i'm like yeah smoking
meat on love now i'm like [ __ ] your
grandma you're my grandmother she's way
traditional than if your mom's
traditional oh she probably [ __ ]
levitated yeah
i smacked the [ __ ] out of you i'm
assuming
if she was able to for sure for sure it
was almost like uh it wasn't shun from
the family or anything but family
meetings were like awkward like
thanksgiving and christmas that you were
just like it got bad did you guys talk
yeah yeah we talked but it was just like
there's like why are you doing this
uh i was 20 at this oh yeah so i was
already moved out so i was already moved
out and everything and making it work um
and that's why i was like that's why
they're kind of okay with it because
they were still kind of like why are you
doing this like you could have just you
know finished like school like you're
going to school and everything because i
was still going to school at that point
and i was like don't worry i'm just
going to finish school you know what i
mean we're going to be all right like
this is how i'm just making money and
everything like it's cool you know i
enjoy it like you can't hate on that and
they were like yeah yeah yeah and they
were like
okay whatever but just don't do [ __ ]
heroin or anything else like [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that because that's really what i
thought it led to and i was like no i
promise i won't like whatever whatever
and then i mean that just kind of like
you know just got softly softly better
from there that was like a couple years
ago at that point and then just we're
just chilling now you know what i mean
were you self-conscious as [ __ ] that
next video no and they're all going to
be yeah yeah yeah richard i was like
damn now my family's watching like this
is weird now this is weird
what's weird for me is when i tell
stories and it's not the best for the
person in the story i changed their
names when they come here
and i'm talking about them and you know
that person well so you know what their
face looks like when you said it when
you brought it up it's like
so
one of my friends
and like it's the worst but the when i i
just dude you got caught i told my
grandma what i was doing
eight years into what i was doing though
oh i kept it a secret for so
[ __ ] only on facebook yeah
because i don't want someone on thomas
or rojo hey isn't that dope as you know
i see you smoking much sweeter
because i've had a couple comments in my
dm's like yo aren't you elmer's son
oh my god oh [ __ ] oh no
what part of my family so i try to keep
it a secret like right until last year
yeah yeah yeah you got the full [ __ ]
crash course yeah yeah i think one of
the funny that the craziest thing that
happened to me like that was some guy
sent a picture of um
he was like i guess a freshman when i
was a senior he took a picture of me in
the yearbook and he was like bro like i
went to the same high school i was like
what the [ __ ]
that's cool bro yeah
it's okay
it's not like you
looking at your phone from behind you
then you're fine because the
[ __ ] are crazy dude i've had
people do some weird [ __ ] but not like
where i'm concerned oh yeah it was just
like send me a picture in front of my
car i'm like bro
don't do that that's weird
you know i'll hit you if you came up to
me and i didn't know what you're talking
to that's super strange it's like yo i
got to be cautious
you know what i'm saying but your car is
your car's it blends well
what do you want to do what do
what kind of purple it's going to be a
deep like like this like galaxy purple
like space purple kind of are you going
to go uh
matt
are you going to go with me gloss
as i'll say enzo tech kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah oh
like space opal gray i mean uh purple
yeah like a midnight purple kind of like
the crushed [ __ ] you wanted to yeah yeah
i wanted to do exactly get the satin
purple satin gloss
oh yeah yeah you're really going to
stand up
yeah but not in a bad way
that's going to be nice yeah it's going
to be kind of professional actually i
love your [ __ ] car so much
the coop is just so bomb
your stick is looking nice man that blue
is good nice thank you blue is nice and
real i mean it's nice and picture soup
in real life it's like damn deep yeah
yeah yeah yeah deep is [ __ ] it's got a
little bit of sparkle in it oh yeah so
slight yes that's what makes it look so
much thought went into that texture oh
yeah oh yeah so studio motors we'll hook
you up with him i'll give his number
after this nice
just dave's the man whatever you need
like he'll like curate what the [ __ ]
you're trying to do you're thinking
he's cool as [ __ ] and [ __ ]
because i was waiting waiting for this
waiting for that and just
waiting for stuff to come in because
with the pan damn it they're like that
color you have to wait a little bit okay
[ __ ] okay how long did the actual wrap
take you know
oh the wrap took like two days no okay
yeah but two work days so it was
probably like six hours total
you know like they just stopped and did
this piece let's just drop do that do
that and we were filming so it kind of
took them longer than normal that's
awesome that's what i definitely want to
go for you have to film yeah 100 after
car channel and everything yeah exactly
bro it's gonna be so sick i'm so excited
[ __ ] yeah
marty
was
plan mercedes
finally i got a win in that [ __ ]
category
good [ __ ] so uh
well we'll be helping marty out with
this car too yeah you guys yeah it's
gonna be fun yeah i know it's like grand
theft auto in real life
i was thinking about it and i was like
what is it going to look like and i was
like wait i can just do it in forza or
like gta yes exactly also it's like yo
what kind of side missions do i got to
do how much is it i'm going to do two
side missions i'll be right back with
the money for this rap and rims
do you ever have a job like a restaurant
job right right yeah yeah did you work i
worked i worked a few jobs so my first
job was um i worked at a chinese
restaurant it was like a little
packaging kind of thing my longest job i
think my most memorable one was um
popeyes
with your friends it was hilarious bro
so it was a new popeyes right next to
our high school and we just turned like
16 in [ __ ] so we all applied and we all
got it pretty much so it was literally
just two managers and all the boys just
like running this popeyes
how much chicken did you trade for wheat
[ __ ]
not that much we stole chicken though
that worked a taco bell that would trade
[ __ ] like here's like 40 bucks of
[ __ ] oh the big ass box is the oh
yeah here's my shirt
give me 10 seconds oh yeah yeah cause i
would go home at the end of the night
they would just let us take everything
and just take it to the plug for sure
but yeah i just got this exactly exactly
it helps yeah i was like i know you're
hungry
it's popeyes it's new it's a new bubba
for sure for sure yo that's a in high
school that means you guys were having
money you worked across the street you
smoked a blunt right after school then
started your shift at four yeah
right
yeah exactly that's a high school
[ __ ] that's what i did i started at
four i got off at 3 20. i smoked some
weed go straight to [ __ ] work just
let's go
all right let's do this we used to work
italian restaurants
italian restaurants
was it cool it was pretty cool i [ __ ]
love machiavelli where were you i was a
host
see i'm telling you when you're tall you
just get to do [ __ ] the other
[ __ ] don't get to do
you're the host in high school yeah yeah
get the [ __ ] out
i thought hoes is where they started you
off at no no the hose is like they look
really nice wear a nice shirt you talk
well you speak proper you're the first
[ __ ] thing that they say we want you
to be the first thing yep they see when
they walk in this restaurant no this is
going to be an all right place
yes
that's all it's usually only girls that
get in high school because if not you
just start off as a buzz boy like every
other dude in america that's crazy
that's so tight it was like you didn't
have to experience did you ever have to
wash dishes and [ __ ] uh at popeyes i
didn't oh okay so you do know what it's
like the worst so the reason i brought
that up is
side missions now you don't have to go
do your popeyes missions in high school
like i'm gonna get those rims in about
eight months it's gonna be sick
now that you're like oh i moved out here
i'm doing more [ __ ] yeah taking like
three days give me three four days i'm
gonna do some [ __ ] and then i'll get
these rims
it's [ __ ] awesome all right it's a
whole different uh
experience in life when you're working
on a motorcycle yeah
cause only you can [ __ ] get your own
money yeah only you can go make [ __ ]
happen you can't have some [ __ ]
telling you know or anything like i'll
do it yeah you'll do it that's it you'll
do it i'm like i'm gonna do it fast like
marty right now you know what i'm saying
like oh yeah it's different man listen
that's my [ __ ] life right now i know
it's completely doing a whole bunch of
gigs huh just a whole bunch of shits at
this house it's like all right we're
going to tackle the [ __ ] bathroom now
we're tackling the paint literally model
action oh yeah full blown nice house oh
that's dope congrats bro and a new car
damn he's leveling up
trip yeah i love it yeah you can
um so speaking of work and working for
yourself
fans oh hold on fan question what's the
second fan question
second fan question coming in
we were ranting like crazy
zane chambers 18.
what's your favorite drug you've done
besides weed
if you want to call wheat or drug
mushrooms for sure same
it's the only one that's not going to
get you living outside but also fun yeah
yeah get you thinking too if you needed
to just have a good time
did you just dabble lightly or do you
like i've been micro dosing recently how
do you like it it's awesome
what's the amount
uh i've been taking anywhere from 0.15
to point three
so like 150 milligrams to 300 milligrams
i never did the milligram i've only done
the capsules what are you doing oh the
capsules oh yeah the capsules so their
point do you think uh point three
capsules right point sevens oh your
point sevens oh so mine's half of that
that's how you say one of those
oh okay how does how does it make you
feel great i love it yeah like it's just
like slightly
more i'd say like energized motivated i
think is the big thing i feel like
motivational
yeah it wakes me up a little bit that's
how i felt yeah yeah people say um it's
equivalent to like your brain is like a
um imagine a snow globe right now it's
just been chilling for a little bit it's
already laid its path and you just don't
shake it up i like that
good that was a good
analogy for that [ __ ] that was tight
yeah then you get like new paths and new
things that you can like carve and like
you just think in a different way almost
mine's always a reset
but the micro dose when i did it it uh
the only thing with it with me it's like
i always feel like a new day once i'm
like back to normal it always feels like
i'm like
oh that was this morning i did that
that's the only reason i don't i mean
the only downfall of microdosing for me
is always feels like i started a new day
when i'm back yeah you know what i'm
saying like when you fall asleep in the
[ __ ] day out of nowhere you wake up
like what the [ __ ] happened that's how i
feel when i take mushrooms in the day
yeah when i take microdoses i should say
because when i take mushrooms i eat a
lot but
yeah i when i normally do
like six or seven
yeah like six seven grams probably but i
sit in my house i don't do [ __ ] yeah
it's a lot darker
it's a good [ __ ] touch
[Music]
he's different he's different he's a
tall man faith is good for me i couldn't
know what it is going anywhere the idea
of talking or going doing it yeah when
you're tripping tripping i don't know
for the first two times i gave him a
strong
dosage and he didn't do [ __ ] to the guy
damn i really had to work
i love those [ __ ] things i've had og
gave me one of those they like you're
saying the nice little perfect little
nuggets in there cool yeah it's cool
burns perfect
so yeah the mushrooms uh your homie
uh i mean your homie the fan question
was from zane chambers 18 what the [ __ ]
yes
i tried to spell it when i said the
first time i got like snatched
that's that alpha brain oh yeah alpha
brain and blunts let's do it
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about another one of our longtime
sponsors this is on it let's get right
into it guys
www.onit.com that's
onnid.com and forward slash yola is our
code that code is going to get you 10
off of everything on the website except
for the weights plus free shipping on
your whole order if you're one of our
fans this is one of our long time
sponsors you already know that on is
human optimization from head to toe
everything you can possibly think of to
get in shape and or your brain better
you're thinking better your cognitive
focus when it comes to the brain alpha
brain you already know that that's their
staple product now they have shots like
i said it's not just for getting buffed
they got gut health digestive tech new
mood shroom tech mct oil vitamin d spray
yes a spray vitamin if you follow marty
on instagram you saw him going hard with
the mct oil and the creatine shakes with
a little emery the other day so once
again guys before i get out of here
www.onit.com that's onnit.com
forward slash yola that's our code use
it anytime you buy anything from on it
online that's going to get you 10 off of
everything like i said but the weights
also free shipping thank you guys so
much for supporting the brands that
support us
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about one of our sponsors this
is betterhelp betterhelp is an online
service essentially for therapy it's not
a crisis helpline so don't think that
you can just call in if you're having a
really hard time you should actually
call a hotline better help us for people
that want to take the steps in getting
better whether it's mental health maybe
it's your confidence maybe it's you know
self-loath whatever it is about you that
you don't like and you want to fix maybe
it's not something you don't like maybe
something you can't deal with on your
own and or it's affecting in other ways
of your life most of us don't have
someone to turn to most of us don't have
that person you can openly be with maybe
you have five brothers and sisters and
you're not open with them about
everything just because they're the
closest people in your life doesn't mean
you're going to be open with them a
therapist from betterhelp is someone
that's licensed that's matched with you
it's not just hey you have eight clients
today throw them in there so if this
interests you at all just go to
betterhelp.com
www.betterhelp.com forward slash dope
and that's 10 off your whole first month
of subscription so give it a try and see
why 2 million people have tried better
help online therapy so it's
betterhelp.com forward slash dope and
that's 10 off your first month of
service this ad read has been brought to
you by better help online therapy thank
you guys so much for watching back to
the episode
so uh here we go
so since we're on the topic of working
and working for yourself when you have
[ __ ] to do
this is a fan question that i think is a
universal fan question what is a typical
work day for you
when it's an actual workday and you have
to get [ __ ] done yeah what is your jet
what is it start off wake up like
hopefully by nine it's probably when i
try to wake up and i'm probably just
doing emails for a couple hours like
just knocking out whatever the [ __ ] you
know and i mean trying to figure out
videos playing videos for like the week
or like upload schedules and everything
um
then phone calls if i need to i usually
schedule those around like lunchtime or
any meetings or whatever lunch time
and then
that's when i'll edit the video for the
day if i need to because i can usually
get i don't know i don't edit
my footage isn't that long so i usually
get an edit out in like two to three
hours oh bomb yeah yeah so i can just
like get you know three hours
yeah yeah yeah and then i'm usually done
by like hopefully five and then i'll
probably after or before editing i'll
get lunch and then after this i'll
probably
answer all the comments answer all the
dms for like an hour or two
and then
dinner with the homie or something or if
there's like an event i feel like that's
what i've been doing recently like
there's a lot of like cool like weed
events or openings or like release
parties or whatever to go to or just
like
networking functions right right yeah i
should like that and then at the end of
the day i'll stream
you stream every day stream every night
yeah yeah every night every single night
no [ __ ] no matter what i mean no matter
what unless i'm like out of town but if
i'm here like capable of streaming for
sure bomb yo yeah what's your top music
going on there recently what's up what's
the top music you got planned just in
your life around your streams because i
know you were saying that you're playing
music on your streams right yeah yeah
yeah i play music on streams um i've
been listening to a lot of like hip hop
rap stuff
uh let's see shorty shorty is probably
my favorite artist i don't know what it
is i've been coming it's been coming up
on my comments nice and i don't know who
that is where's he from uh he's from i
wanna say maryland oh really yeah yeah
baltimore um [ __ ] he's dope he's know
for
sure you listen to hip-hop growing up or
lightly uh yeah kind of i listened to a
lot of alternative growing up so i was
still out like green day like yeah okay
cool so you [ __ ] like 182. yeah
everything 182 some 41 and then like
linkin park see all american rejects no
way red hot chili peppers you know i
mean all those every one of the bands
you just named we have i have my sister
have on when used to tape mtv playing
many videos yeah and we tape it every
single band i remember the all-american
rejects the [ __ ] toss my chemical
romance my killer romance is forever
going to be awesome for sure you're
[ __ ] anybody says i [ __ ] love my
chemical romance i love all that emo kid
[ __ ] it's bomb yeah
so that's what you bumped as a kid all
right you're the first person to not say
like
you know early little wayne
you know which is not a bad thing yeah
it's just i haven't heard anybody say
anything besides hip-hop growing up
right right and then i went
through a little edm face too oh really
really like that i never got into like
i wasn't even doing drugs or anything
either you just liked it
like spongebob jellyfish yeah everyone
called me weird too i just been on the
you know [ __ ] that's just
everybody's
yeah yeah they're like bro what is that
why is he like dancing
in the hallway
not even any lyrics bro she's like
like that's robot music yeah exactly
like that bro it'll catch on trust me
yes so catch this fool's [ __ ]
foreshadowing critiquing i mean uh
curating
crypto edm hey what's the next thing
you're into man
what's the next thing that's gonna
happen huh weed bro oh [ __ ] all right
yeah we're already here all right we're
good this is the next thing we're good
so uh work a work day what's the filming
like because uh i see you do vlogs and
[ __ ]
when you're doing the filming for
yourself
how long how long will you do
total footage time sitting there because
i know you're sitting there going nah
[ __ ] i'm gonna say that again hold on
right yeah 100 sometimes you'll be like
yeah let's done with the sentence
yeah yeah the total video will probably
be like 15 20 minutes and for like an
hour of footage oh okay yeah yeah i
thought you meant that okay
so i cut down like yeah like a fourth of
it always
always right yeah 100 all right what
programs you use uh final cut on let's
go
ahead and tell fools
on my computer because i'm too s i just
premiere pro says i can't do it yeah too
much and but i recently hired an editor
and marty edits the final so i haven't i
don't give a [ __ ] anymore
i don't give a [ __ ] it used to be me and
then i pass it to marty after i'm done
with the skeleton
and now we have some we have someone
named cole doing it for for me and
sending it to marty to like do the
touch-ups okay they both use final cut
also okay that's what i wanted to ask
because everybody that does their own
[ __ ] always uses [ __ ] final cuts
cause it's so goddamn music i'm the only
[ __ ] out here premiere apple's
just got a nice user interface [ __ ]
[ __ ] i guess okay wait they're taking
final cuts for apple
yeah
yeah it's made my apple you [ __ ]
kidding me i all i use is apple [ __ ]
you gotta get on it people need to
explain things better to me i think i
think about yo this is what it's for
it's made for this computer i would
never use [ __ ] premiere premieres
adobe that's where i just know adobe i
don't know i would you know i'll just
stop i was about references
this reference movie just off the word
adobe and [ __ ] pee wee herman we'll
just stop apple's cool because they'll
like they'll
utilize the most out of your hardware
for sure like a program like final cut
will run on most people
like max you know
just
you're from
texas pee wee herman's big adventure you
ever seen it no oh never mind never mind
oh
because never mind for everyone out
there that knew what i was about to ask
yeah you have to watch did you ever [ __ ]
with peter hammond as a kid no hockey is
so cool i feel like it sounds familiar
though pee wee herman paul you ever seen
blow
with johnny depp yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know his homie derek for real
yeah yeah okay that's petey herman oh
yeah so he's here with the tie
he's a kid's show but he's also doing
[ __ ] rails with everybody he's like
uh if blue's clues full steve was down
as [ __ ]
that's pee-wee herman all right that's
awesome he's a good actor too yeah um so
that was totally off topic
my bad
movies just keep going what's your
favorite movie oh thank you diego
serrano 209 oh
209 you picked a 209.
third question that's where i'm from
yes merced
yeah i'm from uh let's see
saving private ryan what's your favorite
movie good [ __ ] answer that's so sad
it's a great movie though i almost cried
when i was like [ __ ] seven and i
watched it and the kid screaming for his
mom at the time yeah
oh my god oh my god i can't watch this
that's that's your favorite movie it's a
cinematic answer yeah yeah it's a
beautiful movie for sure
a man's favorite movie says a lot
that's funny because
another [ __ ] tom hanks classic
i was going to say this or it's true
my two favorites
damn stephen private brian is so sad so
many good actors died
they stabbed that little man through the
throat that's it was so sad the other
one's probably the dark knight honestly
oh my favorite nolan movie even though
he's got like a lot of bangers but i
like dark knight oh you talking about
the director directing that damn you
know the
i director know
what else did you do he's got a like
inception
oh he does all the crazy [ __ ] yeah he
does like tenant and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
me up
i'm still i watched that like eight
months ago and i'm still trying to
figure
i had to watch a 30-minute clip on
youtube of someone explaining it i still
don't
because it doesn't make sense a human
brain not supposed to compute that yeah
it doesn't make sense inception it was
kind of dope that he did that
was like yo
i just didn't you gave birth to your dad
like
the [ __ ] you just said they're doing it
all the [ __ ] i'm my own dad's dad that's
what the [ __ ] tanning is yeah
yeah it doesn't make sense that's 10
good movie
didn't get it crazy yeah so uh here we
go you've been going hard as [ __ ] with
the glass lately i've been seeing you
chilling with fools that are just
going hard
going on these guys like what i was
trying
you know there's car culture yeah shrink
that car into a glass same price there's
glass culture and it's absolutely insane
so you've been going hard i've been
seeing this [ __ ] in the events trying to
just get plugged in it's cool bro just
meeting all the people like
it's crazy yeah little case you brought
with your [ __ ] slides yeah yeah
you're seeing all the like walks of life
honestly it's like almost like oh yeah
just seeing everyone
from the books
that probably know the dudes that made
it all the way up to the guys that sell
bricks they also just like dabs right
right yeah those are those are fun
people though yeah they're all lit
they're closed you always can tell
because they have one or two gold teeth
yeah and the [ __ ] cuban it's just
like too big seven lean yeah yeah
exhibit oh you sell bricks you just like
dabs too old carts you sell carts too
buy the hundred thousand you don't say
that's pretty much the dab culture in
l.a yeah for sure so you've been seeing
it all yeah it's crazy [ __ ] you've seen
so far
for all the [ __ ] fans out there that
really are into this [ __ ] cuz i you go
hard with the turf slurpers i will say
that that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up it makes me
not want to keep dabbing
it's like one and i'm done kind of thing
that's that's that's what it used to be
for me but now i'm just building the
talent oh it's so heavy it's so it's
smoking it gets you so high [ __ ] up
you mainly dab
uh i'd say i died most of the time do
you really
it's like 60 40. it's like pretty close
but i like to have it a little bit dab
right now yeah like that right you have
one yeah yeah yeah okay
we just dropped the push trees right
right i got you
as soon as you leave
you just tell me which one [ __ ] yeah dab
right it's essential it's focused owners
are super dope too shout out to yeah
ownership right yeah they're cool people
they're cool as [ __ ] actually
so what is the craziest thing class wise
you've seen
oh because i know there's
you know what i mean by crazies like
what's the one piece you did not want to
drop
you know what i'm saying dude yeah the
one piece
it's probably uh
my homie mikey has an insane collection
of glass and he's got some pieces like
that where i'm like not scared to hit
him because you can't be scared that's
when you psych yourself out you know and
i mean i'm suck myself
i don't care i'll do this yeah you dab
it you use it i'll just put my mouth
yeah yeah but after being around so long
you can just you know you handle him and
everything but his his pieces are
absolutely insane he used to um or i
guess he still does but he used to
collect like fine art like on the walls
and [ __ ] he was like
[ __ ] this like i can't smoke out of him
so he started to collect like glass art
instead
and like the same amount so like 50 70
100 000 rigs just by the regular like
insane one-of-ones he'll fly to the
artist's house just to get it made see
it and then like bring him back that's
that real dope connoisseur it's that
dope [ __ ] for sure bro shout out to my
god mikey he's super dope
um but yeah it's like all his pieces are
insane and like that's like the culture
you know and i mean just
disrespecting glass especially these
like big artists that really put their
like soul into it you know and like you
get like an old piece and it's like oh
this guy made it in 2012 and you're like
what it's like 10 years old like look
how old it is but it's still like being
used to this day and [ __ ] it's awesome
dude those one-of-ones are irreplaceable
also they're all one of ones damn near
you know are they really i mean it to a
certain degree you know even if if it's
on a lathe by an artist like even if he
tries to make the same exact thing over
and over she's gonna be like this
slightly oh yeah the collabs that are
like yeah the collabs are 101 for sure
but
yeah all the artists is super dope
they're all what's your favorite piece
in your collection man
the one you would not get rid of
oh
i don't know if i won't get rid of it
because i'm good
because i'm trying to open it by this
artist mike luna is probably my favorite
artist right now and i have an orb by
him they call it it's like the dragon
claw oh with the scene yeah yeah yeah
yeah rips for being such a little
[ __ ] piece yeah i love that thing but
the one when you first came yo oh yeah
the little one so i'm trying to sell
that and he makes full of dragons so i'm
gonna sell that one to my homie is it
the dragons that do this they're
standing there and they have their hand
on the ball yeah you've seen this artist
before oh yeah my friend's got a couple
of those he's the uh
johan from [ __ ]
i'm sure you've seen him on instagram he
posts like the 10 pound slabs of butter
he posts all those dragons a collection
of those dragons man
yo fleet real quick he bought two
dragons from the artist
we're in seattle at cannabis cup real
quick story he's standing there buying
another one
with his cases between his feet
looks down someone snatched him right
from [ __ ] under him as he's paying
for another one no one said [ __ ] they
might have saw him pick him up no no
[ __ ] full ran off with him right
[ __ ] guy runs off with him and he
looks at me and i see him 10 minutes
later and he's just white
about to puke just heartbroken i can see
he's like someone stole my [ __ ] it's
almost all my [ __ ] pieces i bought
today and there you know they're like
[ __ ] 12 bands of people yeah [ __ ]
he just lost like 30k right there
and he's all hurt
so we're trying to make him feel better
he comes back to my booth man i'll just
take some dads bro he's just like you
can see it on his face he doesn't want
to be at the cannabis cup anymore it's
over yeah so
he posts i posted on my dm i mean i
posted my story he posted it on his page
we posted it everybody we know and all
the people in my booth at the time are
like all fools that make videos so
combined we got a lot of eyeballs like
yo post that [ __ ] right now yeah before
it [ __ ] leaves this place
nobody said [ __ ] like two hours later
someone dm's him and says hey man i just
bought these two cases from these guys
in the parking lot
and i opened them up and i saw on bozo's
page at the same [ __ ] rigs that i
just bought
and he's like out right here if you want
to come get them the guy sold to him for
50 bucks a [ __ ] case because they
couldn't open it because my homie has
his locks on it and they just thought
they were just pelicans [ __ ] it here
boom always like 150 bucks a case
they sold for 300 bucks and the guy's
like bro i just bought the k i thought
they were just cases i'm like [ __ ] yeah
i'll buy how much for these [ __ ]
cases and when he got him he's like oh
what the [ __ ] these are sick i looked at
his instagram and saw everybody on earth
posting the [ __ ] eggs yeah she's like
i'm not trying to be a piece of [ __ ] so
he went and met my homie my homie like
here's [ __ ] iraq thank you so much
and he gave him like it's like two zips
of concentrates or some [ __ ] he's like
thank you so much because my homie makes
so much right like right bam hear
everything in my bag take it all day
yeah yeah and he [ __ ] got it back
like two hours later the only time on
earth someone got their glass back yeah
that's amazing the power of social media
[ __ ] guys the [ __ ]
god didn't even know what he's sitting
on yeah and he's like there's some dude
in a [ __ ] hoodie
he just ran into a jeep like oh bro
fools are just smashing grabbing people
that's [ __ ] up they buy a ticket to
try to come up with the cannabis cup
right just to steal you said it was in
seattle it was in seattle it was [ __ ]
up it was sad but he got it back man but
i remember seeing my friend go uh ghost
white it's not the fun it's not fun
yeah get robbed
that lasted a long time that was great
it wasn't harsh at all
good smoke all the way through i just
don't do the blunts and that was fine do
you have a any more you have a still
gone yeah yes okay cool for sure
so next thing real quick i just want to
talk to you about since we talked about
it and it's very very relevant
you're getting [ __ ] played on uh
social media oh yeah it's starting to
get out there starting to get bad yeah
so you still don't have your instagrams
nah not the main instagrams what's your
instagram now erican.ig
oh yeah rsck
dot ig
yeah yeah so we can pop that [ __ ] up yes
yes so
is that your for how many times you've
been delayed was how many accounts have
you had is this your second third this
is this is my second account my main
account it's been deleted countless
times but i always got it back
within i mean the longest it ever took
was like three four weeks so once it
passed that amount like a couple weeks
ago i was like oh [ __ ] this is serious
did you do the
picture yeah i didn't done that a couple
times don't even send me that email
anymore it's crazy that means that one's
done damn [ __ ] that's what happened to
me once they stopped sending me the
email for it yeah it died wow i have
another link you could try i haven't yet
it doesn't work for me yeah it's working
for everyone else i've ever given it to
though wow i'll give it to you guys i'll
give it to you um so
you got [ __ ] played on instagram
classic right yeah so your new one up
and going you're doing your thing
youtube this is a whole nother thing
so when we talk about it we talk about
trying not to get demonetized and age
restricted right off the bat
this is what we're talking about
you sir
i have a lot of [ __ ] subscribers and
your views
are looking like my views right now yeah
bad they do not like two years ago if we
got those views you go what the [ __ ]
happened did people not see it yeah yeah
for sure but now it's almost like a
customer and like yeah i understand why
it's happening it takes like i used to
get 100k in a day yeah every 24 hours
124 hours i was like this benchmark and
now it's like four days
oh it is like that yeah yeah if that
right now yeah but it'll get it'll gain
but it'll eventually get there but it's
like it's heartbreaking yeah it's not
the views it's more of like
what am i doing i did so much time into
this yeah yeah yeah none of my audience
even got to watch it yeah 100 like i
know they would have enjoyed it but they
didn't even see it would love it yeah
they got to see it yeah hear people i
haven't seen you post in weeks but bro i
post every [ __ ] week what are you
talking about yeah
they just haven't seen it pop up yeah
when i typed you in youtube you have to
type the whole thing in click it and
then find it yeah you're no longer
popping up anymore
like eric you're falling off like [ __ ]
you it's youtube hey man you're just
playing me if anything i did really good
youtube's like no no slow this down
it's too fast right that's really what i
think it is i just i guess i've just
combated it by uploading more videos so
i've gotten like more views per month
technically like my numbers are up
technically like it's a better month for
me than than the past few for sure like
the best month and like the past six or
seven for sure but
just because i'm uploading a lot more
the videos aren't necessarily getting
more views it's just like the same
people that watch them are just staying
loyal and unrespected and i appreciate
you yeah
but it's like
a little bit like i said last week i
usually upload one once a week i did
three videos last week yeah oh the
door's open it's the first train we've
heard in so long
it's kind of nice we left the door open
for the puppy sorry for everyone that
heard the train the train that's the
first time we've heard the care packages
that's hilarious that door is doing
something yeah it is huh
um
so you're getting played hard are you
monetized
on youtube no you're not mine i could
channel this
i try every month because you have to
like disable it for a month
and i'll get it like once every three or
something like that oh and i'll get
monetized for like a week i'll be like
yeah and then i could just monetize but
i can't monetize any videos the only
thing you can do is get super chats for
streams which is pretty cool oh so they
got you like brushed off to the side
right right right you're monetized yeah
yeah gotcha but i don't i can't monetize
any videos but then that gets taken away
like eventually so they tell me to that
my content's too explicit and if i want
i have to basically start my channel
over um erase everything that's what
they told me for the [ __ ] plaque
that's what they told me for the plaque
if i wanted the plaque i was like
i ain't doing that yeah i was like i was
getting another channel like [ __ ]
faces yeah
crazy asses yeah if you like car content
so what what is it more eric yeah more
john on youtube yes so you're dropping
multiple car videos i'm trying to just
build the [ __ ] out of this car i'm going
to lower it tune it
it's going to be even louder than it is
now it's going to plan on keeping that
yeah for a little bit what i really like
i like the stars in the roof
there's a company out here that blue
johnson yeah there's a place that yeah
there's a lot of places
if you're gonna keep the car you could
put the rolls royce stars in your move
that's insane it looks bomb i know it's
just a little thing
but it's like as a kid when you stick
the [ __ ] glow stars the green ones
you turn your lights off like
i'm outside come on man that's what it's
like in your car
it's [ __ ] cool it's just a little
thing as a kid it's about you can do as
an adult yeah you get a dream car
yes uh my dream car
um
there's multiple oh
what's your dream garage
oh i like that question good [ __ ]
um
i like the like i said the first car i
almost got was like a 59 cadillac i
almost bought this old man okay so 59
cadillac i like the 62 lincoln with the
suicide doors oh like those old boats
one two
and if i could i'd have like a
68
super sport nova probably
bomb and then my car i have the money
the monte carlo the the 86
but newer cars
there's this orange guts
with
the forgiato f orange yeah and the brake
pad orange but it's a rolls-royce dawn
oh it's this orange inside
that i was going to say the orange
interiors
royce that [ __ ]
and the cullinan you've seen the suv
rolls royce my homies got it it's so
nice
it's nice it's like a bench in the back
and [ __ ] he doesn't drive you make
someone drive him he's like well i don't
want to drive if he's [ __ ] all this
cool all right i understand it's awesome
but in the middle you know your center
console in the back seat yeah is a ice
cooler do you know that in the room
it's just his hash
it because it keeps hash perfect
it's a wine cooler bro he's like i don't
put drinks in here just [ __ ] throw my
head dude and it's like all perfectly
like
it's so cool it's so fun sickest thing
ever it's so fun that's awesome um
there's this hermes uh
g uh g wagon but i'm not into the g
wagon as much anymore yeah it was in the
overrated they're too much i was in the
urus the other day loved it the exhaust
straight pipes loved it
so i kind of that's when i said when you
pulled up like oh
i think i need to need it loud
not even like just if i want to go
down the [ __ ] freeway and i can hear
it still it's fun yeah yeah i never
really liked it yeah it adds more like
to the car yeah that's the experience
yeah yeah people think it's for like to
be annoying and [ __ ] but it's really
just to like add to the experience and
there are some annoying exhausts oh yeah
that doesn't sound normal yeah yeah
yours is not like oh it's different you
know it sounds cool it sounds like bomb
sounds like it's [ __ ] growling it
doesn't sound like the machine gun [ __ ]
oh yeah my homie's got the aventador the
lambo one and it sounds like machine
guns it's not fun
you don't want to do crazy yeah
and people like what the [ __ ]
it's like yo that's attention grabbing
yeah that i don't need because i'm
smoking joints i don't need that
attention bro oh yeah but i get the
exhaust like yours i love that [ __ ] oh
gee did his
and i'm like yo
stepping on like mine's quiet i don't
like this [ __ ] no more because i don't
know how to do the crackle [ __ ] mine
does it but i've only done it once in
the free i went oh that was my [ __ ] i
don't know how it works man i just drive
my [ __ ] car i don't know i'm not a
car guys
but it's fun it is fun so that's the the
dr i guess that'd be the dream
i just don't like a lot of newer cars
they're not fun to me
like they don't have that same but like
the mansonry package oh all of them are
sick
the man i like the bra
my dream was the bravo's gt-63s
but it's also like 700 bands and that's
no no thank you yeah that's crazy no
[ __ ] 100
goddamn that's insane no you can get a
few nice cars yeah for sure but it's 900
horsepower oh it is the beastly it's the
most beastly car you could get also i
don't go fast so just be more like hey i
like that b you got robin speed
that's all it would be for yeah
yeah it is fast as [ __ ] it's a 700
horsepower jeep it is fastest and it
looks good it's got the hellcat engine
in it it looks so random it's random as
[ __ ] they put it all under jeep who
knows
who knows
so what's your dream garage oh [ __ ]
probably
uh the only i'd have one classic in
there and it's probably like
oh
man a certain like fastback
mustang probably oh really yeah yeah
from like probably the 70s or something
72 i think yeah like talking about the
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that's the classic in there this
sports car i'd probably have a porsche
on a porsche which
but one of them one of them for sure the
gt4 is sick because it's the mid-engine
one it's the only one they make
um it's a little more affordable too so
that's like the affordable one for sure
affordable you mean not 290 it's 280.
those cars are [ __ ] expensive yeah
yeah that one goes for one like 20.
yeah
what yeah well it's starting out you
probably paid a little bit tax for like
130 probably for the gt4 oh i must not
know which one this is yeah the gt3 is
the one that's like 200 down here oh
maybe that's what i'm tripping maybe
that's yeah yeah that one's super sick
the rear engine classic 911. the 911
turbo s my friend guy oh the extended
one because my friend's big 60 that's
it's yeah that's up there almost 300
yeah he's a big dude my homie just got
he's a big dude so he's like the
terrible ass i fit in damn
that's
so cool
that's a sick car it's super fast super
fast it's one of the fastest like
production cars i don't know how to do
that it's insane so it's in the cali
roads
there's certain roads out there i just
no going car that's going that fast this
is [ __ ] scary man man i threw my [ __ ]
and [ __ ] sport on the way up bit i
was like god damn this thing's getting
away from me did you okay
don't go to sport plus yet did that say
make sure you're chilling first yeah
i've already got the car last night and
we discovered together goes what is this
button to go
click it sports sports plus like yo you
yes we were figuring it all out last
night
um yeah so all this car stuff the reason
i'm like oh my friend did that one
because that's the only time i would
ever know what the car was because i
don't know about cars so he's like it's
a 911 turbo something like oh
all right so now i know what a poor
something 911 looks like now i know what
a rolls royce no because i'm not good
with the [ __ ] yeah i google stuff and go
fast cars what do i google i don't know
you're not studying the different
classes and models no i don't know that
stuff but there are if you ever go to
mansuri.com
oh my god their shit's insane right
you know what i'm talking about i
already won
uh bugatti one it's all [ __ ] carbon
fiber it's like a green
is so sick if that's the one i'm
remembering right that's it yeah but
cars like that don't interest me yeah
they're spending millions of dollars a
little bit too much even if you're a
billionaire i'd be like bro how was your
spin on tires yeah this is stupid yeah
yeah i can't help but family out with
the tires that's what i'm saying
i'm saying i gotta do that to myself i
just feel like a piece of [ __ ] that's
too much for sure certain cars
so real quick
right here
question you say you do [ __ ] with
mushrooms yes you ever had the bad
experience
no honestly i've got some wood yeah yeah
yeah but
yeah usually i just
yeah even especially microdosing it's
been amazing experiences um but the huge
doses the big doses they've been they've
been chewed you know sometimes it starts
to get away like five i think experience
for sure mushroom capsules uh they're
mushrooms that's five
capsules work great dangers work great
gummies are great nothing is the same as
actual raw mushrooms yeah i don't know
what it is do you how do you eat them
you just eat them like mushrooms you
ready for the tag yes i need i used to
eat them and they were disgusting i put
them on pizza i rolled them up tortillas
i did whatever roll ups or whatever it's
always [ __ ] ass okay so ready yeah
detect what i learned from somebody like
yo you just said for a roll up like you
got what you got to do is lay out a
fruit roll up two of them
put a thin layer of [ __ ] mushrooms
and just roll it slightly and then start
adding a little more and a little more
and a little more so when you bite each
bite it like
coats it so i was just
eating them and not even tasting
mushrooms
because if you kind of place it like
sushi almost like a wrap
you're rolling it so you can take a bite
and when you bite it it like forms
around chewing chewing chewing gum
swallow it nice somebody told me that
[ __ ] on a dm when instagram first got
dms i was like
i'm gonna i'm gonna try this late and
whoever you are thank you so much you
changed the whole thing try the fruit
roll up but like you can't just stuff it
yeah that's what i was doing because
then handle it yeah that's exactly what
i was doing
it's disgusting everything of just yeah
it's a whole [ __ ] full burrito
right right exactly with a little bit of
sweet exactly no you gotta
you can't cook cook them in like a
regular burrito right i don't know i
don't know i don't know
but i don't know how they make tea they
do they do make teas but they don't it's
not singed
like when you cook it does it cook the
properties away i know acid you can't
burn but i don't know really mushrooms
acid too right yes it's pretty cool but
i like mushrooms way better i've been an
acid in a while i haven't done acid
before oh i've never done it the reason
is because my pepper had her best friend
in high school they used to ask a lot
and her friend one day just was a
schizophrenic oh that's what happened to
my father oh she went she's still
full-blown schizophrenic yeah dude bad
but she was predisposed to having she's
a friend because her mama
and then one day i'm like yo what's
wrong with your friend she's over here
yelling and like yeah looking at us
weird like i don't like her yeah dude
that's exactly what's happening to my
homie that's crazy really how bad is he
still bad uh honestly
damn it's pretty [ __ ] he passed away
like a couple weeks ago oh [ __ ] yeah
super [ __ ] up i got i got a text from
my best homie he was like yo bro like
oh i'm sorry away yeah it's cool bro but
like yeah he was that's honestly the
craziest probably story that i've ever
had was tripping [ __ ] acid with this
guy he was uh he's a crazy guy man a
real lovable guy i've actually had him
in a couple videos before too just
[ __ ] crazy but um [ __ ] we were
tripping acid before a [ __ ] football
game and this was already when we both
stopped playing football i was like
senior year in high school so we were
just playing this for well yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we were just [ __ ]
you know it means getting high with all
the homies and [ __ ] and we're walking to
the [ __ ] football stadium and like
all the lights are going on you know i
mean they can hear the crowd and
everything and like you're going to take
a booth
and then it's me my homie in front of me
and then
uh the homie behind me
and then um
is it
me and me and like homie a who's uh okay
so homie nick is the one who passed away
alright nick and um this is my other
homie so we're chilling and then nick's
behind us and then we kind of like look
behind
and then he's just like
she's like tripping we can tell he's
tripping we're like probably okay
he's like you guys see those aliens
we're like
we're like no bro like it's just it's
just the stadium he's like dude they're
right there and he starts like tripping
he's like hiding behind [ __ ] and we're
like nah bro like we're doing like nah
we're just going like you know it's just
like the football game we're trying like
we kind of realized that he's tripping
we're like no no no like a little
football game you know we're doing bro
you know we're just gonna watch some
football and then he's just like no bro
i can't do this and he turns around and
just like sprints the other way oh and
we have to be like no jason like yeah
yeah we have to chase him but he's like
he's honestly like a pretty fast and fit
[ __ ]
he's going like through the cars and
[ __ ] and we just like we just lose him
like literally through the [ __ ]
he was the running back bull we wanted
to [ __ ] catch him
yeah exactly and then we were just like
damn we're really tripping so we're just
like oh cause you guys are an ass too
but he was kind of close but he was kind
of close we were like he probably just
ran home
let's go to the game we're like okay
then we go to the game and i was just
tripping [ __ ] nutsack in the stands
and [ __ ] it was hilarious
yeah yeah
he ended up alright
yeah that was [ __ ] crazy last i saw
him that night saw him the next day and
he was like yeah bro sorry i just saw
some [ __ ] and i'd leave and i was like i
can't respect that like no schizophrenic
yeah yeah
after that night not after that night
but eventually like did just
oh cause he kept taking this yeah he
kept taking action
that's what scares me yeah yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying because i can
take mushrooms a lot nothing happens but
you're fine with mushrooms yeah exactly
you say yeah
who knows do you actually see [ __ ] on
mushrooms though or is it more like yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah i'm tripping
[ __ ] nut sack on mushrooms it's very
it's very identical like the actual the
only thing that's different i would say
about an identical trip to like
you know if you take i'd say a tab of
acid like a hundred micrograms it's
probably like
two two and a half grams of shrooms or
something like that oh it's in a trip
yeah yeah yes it's a good little solid
trip and um the only difference is the
acid the high is a little bit higher but
the come down is so rough it's just like
shroom come down to just you know you
level off and then you can probably
smoke to get it off and then you can
probably like you know chill somewhere
that night like you can go somewhere
that night but acid come down it's just
like your brain's like wired you're
going and it feels so weird you feel
shitty
it's horrible like there's like an acid
hangover that people know like the day
after you don't feel that great at all
like you're just it's weird it's that's
so funny it doesn't sound funny yeah
it's not fun at all maybe i want to ask
him it's not that great it's i mean i'd
say you're not missing really much as
long as you're just doing some great
troops i love mushrooms that's what i'm
saying same thing he's awesome yeah i'll
just stick with that
okay yeah i just think it does let you
know because i was supposed to tell you
maybe the acid vlog maybe if i find some
scientists who's like no this is this
this this is this one yeah yeah
let's film this [ __ ]
that's a different story oh we feel like
a science experiment typically that'd be
awesome like the psychic substance dude
you've seen this
he's supposed to come here but he's in
canada
so there were some border things going
on so that's the only reason why he
hasn't been here yeah yeah we talked to
him a little bit ago i'm excited excited
he's super dope
i used to watch him way back in the day
like when i first started [ __ ] just
watching just i like videos i like
the depth that he goes into oh yeah 100
good [ __ ] and he actually does hit
everything i [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
it's pretty cool man
he's got a good thing going oh yeah i
think like better better than a hamilton
show but the only thing about the
hamilton show they travel they meet this
that's what makes that show so sick yeah
but the psychic substance guy i think
trips harder yeah that's why i like it
more but the hamilton show is sick i
[ __ ] with that show he's not restricted
and [ __ ] too it's kind of yeah that's
cool
i know how though
maybe because it's super educational
person
i guess so i don't think he really like
does he really show him i guess he just
shows him
i guess off the side i guess so yeah and
just telling you and showing you what's
going on yeah i guess that's funny yeah
but the thumbnails
true
i watched a guy smoke [ __ ] fentanyl
on software don't everybody belly today
you watched software underwater yes bro
wait he smoked it on the show youtube
yeah
excuse me it was [ __ ] crack and
fentanyl oh hell no what a mixture what
the [ __ ] what kind of mixture is that
pretty sure yeah yeah we'll go to sleep
and do these mushrooms that's why for
what crack and fentanyl that's not fun
that's something yeah
no [ __ ] thank you um software
underbelly's crazy
real quick
where can everybody find everything that
you do
you can find it on
erican on youtube erickcon.ig on
instagram and
i guess i know what did i do with the
game oh yeah twitter aircon underscore
at the end yeah oh you're lucky
lucky you got that one
people steal everything that was my
instagram when i got deleted so we'll
see
oh that's right oh do you have it the
same all the way across yeah i had it
the same oh it's so much better i know
because i just feel like on everything i
have so many underscores
i have so many periods and underscores
yeah yeah honestly when i type in at
dope it does ubi though so that's cool
that's cause you follow me i think
it has to be yeah that's for sure it's
like stripes like you know it's your war
stripes and social media platforms
[ __ ] tear drops
that's the digital
yeah i got 17 underscores man but doing
this 25th account
so that's where everybody can find your
[ __ ] oh yeah anova
smoke novasmoke.com right or yeah we
want to keep up the date with the drop
it's anova.ig on instagram ig oh yeah we
post where there's going to be so what's
new for you what's the next step as you
all right ready
you came here you were eight days in now
you're just under nine months
what's the next step for you because i
remember when you said i'm trying to
meet a new person every day yeah and
then you went that's a little
unrealistic let's dial it back a little
bit i'll try and meet another person
every week yeah new connection this
what's your next step for la since you
you're living here you're having [ __ ]
fun
trying to um dabble into different
industries kind of thing so my homies
are like real connected into like the
music [ __ ] like he does a lot like music
videos and stuff so like i like dabbling
into there like maybe connecting wheat
over there like you know what i mean
like business people here maybe they
like weed like um i've been meeting a
lot of people in gaming recently that
are really [ __ ] with weed from like
certain like like phase clan and optic
and [ __ ] that are really [ __ ] with
weeds so it's not after they were like
two weeks ago yeah it's crazy yeah it's
crazy bro it's crazy so it's just like
yeah diving into all these like because
everyone's here you know what i mean
everyone's in lsu [ __ ] like like the
culture of america is always in l.a
right right so i'm just trying to bring
weed to all these places
that's cool
so your your thing is basically
the dot connector from weed to this weed
to blank right right that's cool yes
all right you know it's kind of funny
that you say that you know what i did
last night and it's really funny
last night my homie ratchet man he's a
you know homie ratchet the big dude with
the long hair in my videos and [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's a spanish artist like a legit
spanish artist he does music he
makes music right
he got invited to the kings game
last night to be like the featured
artist or whatever like i interviewed
him during espn latin and all this [ __ ]
he's like hey i want to bring my friend
and he stand on my [ __ ] and go oh [ __ ]
we should have him to speak on this well
i'm like all right that's fine i don't
care it's like full let's vlog it so we
filmed it so into the king's game last
night we go up to the top
i don't speak spanish dude
and last night it's like a spanish
broadcast it's a espn
latin last night i was doing the
announcement during the second period of
the kings game on espn latin i don't
speak spanish bro i didn't know what we
were doing fully and as i'm sitting
there putting a headstand i'm like
oh [ __ ] okay we're in all right so
everybody is saying spanish spanish
spanish i'm like
oh that was a good this good shot man
it's a good shot and i don't watch
hockey like that i like it it was sick
to go to the game yeah yeah i've seen it
before but bro i don't know hockey well
and i don't know spanish but last night
i pulled it off and it sounded pretty
good nice so that's the other world i
went into last night
sports it does the rams too so hopefully
but you know next time come do the rams
me by oh bro i'll do the whole [ __ ]
game with you if it's football
but it was really funny because i can
hear them saying spanish saying spanish
during omar's part of the interview yeah
so thomas and he go like [ __ ] man this
fool had to stop what he was doing to go
back to english on the spanish network
[ __ ] this isn't a good look not a good
look but it was very funny yeah it was i
can't that's awesome that sounds dope as
[ __ ] it was cool but at the end like i
gotta learn spanish
because we were talking about it like
late night tv shows like david letterman
all these [ __ ] yeah yeah those guys
are not going to be around doing the
shows for very much longer for sure i
feel like are the shows that we have
like you're you have a show yeah yeah
your channel is a show that's you you're
the show same with me
those i feel like the ones that are
solid
once i actively post that actively on
their [ __ ]
are gonna be around for a long time i
feel like that's the next wave of oh
yeah like
content tv stuff yeah things 100 percent
hundreds of netflix thing is going to be
like no no like those tick tocker fools
that have the house or whatever i don't
know who the [ __ ] they were i mean they
got a netflix show yeah
like no nobody watches there's nobody
there's no words yeah all these networks
are gonna like because they're all
competing like [ __ ] even like vice or
something like get into like one of
those or
you know all these like apple music or
apple mtv or whatever they all want
original artists and original things to
go with today what you just said if
you're trying to do this with music and
try to connect to gaming
those are the two industries that [ __ ]
with weed yeah yeah you can make the
connection on that because i saw
something earlier you said something
about pine park oh yeah what is it park
what is that so pine park is a gaming
area it's not a game company it's a weed
company that's out here in california
and it's started by optic hex who's the
owner of the optic gaming kind of clan
and they're an esports team that's been
around for like i don't even know how
long i think started in call of duty but
they're across like so many different
um esports now but he dabbled in the
that for a little bit he's been building
that team like creating i think it's
like it's one of the biggest like fan
bases in [ __ ] video games type [ __ ]
you know i mean it's crazy like they're
their fan base mexican guy right yeah
yeah yeah i saw a picture with you and
him yeah yeah yeah so he's super dope so
he built a weed company he just started
one and then um we've been working
together for a little bit and then now
i'm doing some marketing and cannabis
content for them and [ __ ] and it's dope
they offered me part equity so i'm a
part owner now
an illegal wheat company an illegal weed
company
i didn't know that they sell weed in the
stores yeah yeah yeah in the stores
let's go that's how you do it all right
man so the more content you do for your
own [ __ ] the more it's like but i have
equity yeah so if it does great i do
great
good [ __ ] bro congratulations thank you
that is gonna buy you a house in a
couple years yeah that's what i'm hoping
for and it's amazing stuff
let's go oh
nice i thought was just i thought it was
uh the podcast oh no no no i thought it
was just the part because i saw you on a
podcast yeah
and then when we were i was on your live
early i'm like let me see what this was
doing yeah and he was like
you're all pine park and that's when we
got off and i started like getting ready
yeah yeah so that's how they built their
um that's how they built optics so they
had like they were the only really
esports team with a big youtube channel
and like instagram and content and
everything so they're like let's do that
same thing with yeah let's do that same
thing with [ __ ] weed spar
smart good good job for them good job
guys
grab the guy that yeah you already did
gaming heavily right this is your shift
yeah yeah because i already like knew
that it was honestly like a dream
because i already watched all his [ __ ]
like i watched all of his podcasts and
[ __ ] like when he owned the team like i
was super involved this guy before yes i
was always a big fan but he didn't know
me you know you've been type [ __ ] yeah
so i was like damn like this is crazy to
me
right to be like working with you ready
sign that [ __ ] you already done it yeah
yeah it's done
a couple days ago like two days ago like
two days ago
wow so they selling the stores and now
you have equity that's huge man that's
pretty awesome you move down here and
listening
let's go good [ __ ] see man i'm [ __ ]
so glad you're moving out here i was
always telling you always tell god
goblins
goblins you have to let's go
opportunity like you said now it's crazy
it went from finding to sifting through
what you want right right it's not like
oh they're not paying enough it's more
of i don't want to do that whack ass
product
i don't want to do that [ __ ] i don't
want to do this that people won't like
that if like i said if you did every
single thing you'd have 60 videos a
month yeah exactly and people don't want
i don't i know you don't right
around you you might as well just stop
doing what you're doing
cash out for a month like [ __ ] no it's
not worth it like that so good man so
the more content you do basically the
more content pushes the we brand yeah
let's go more legal money you made
[ __ ] good job i'm excited for you
thank you good job man i didn't know
that you're a [ __ ] part owner now
yeah it's pretty awesome bro well where
can everybody find it in la
uh it's in let's see kaliva it's that's
a little uh
yeah yeah yeah and then it's in you can
just check the website for like a list
of dispensaries about how to leave is
the main one
pine park yeah
hq dot com i believe
hq
on google okay so that's where they can
find all the shops that they're at 100
what's up with the string coming out
you're gonna have australian coming out
or what oh
well we have a uh an undecided one
actually that we're gonna let the fans
decide on good that's cool yeah so we
have this
the aircon
series yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
come on man
they knew what they were doing when they
were like yo you want to be part owner
good
yeah [ __ ] it run it up yeah good [ __ ]
perfect it's exactly what you needed man
all right now you don't get paid from
youtube but and so you get paid from
youtube yeah
exactly so it's like it's more
motivating at the same time you know
what i mean i'm like [ __ ] the views are
tanking that's [ __ ]
that sucks but also the fans that are
there are supporting you no matter what
right right even if your views are going
like oh man [ __ ] youtube you dick
yeah they're dipping a little no matter
what those hardcore fans are there yeah
yeah they can go support you real real
life right right they're gonna it's
awesome for sure that's why i like the
the anova stuff into stuff too because
it feels like because they know you're
helping yeah yeah they know right and
you're helping out an artist yeah and
that's helping out just by buying stuff
they like yeah yeah exactly you're just
paying someone's you know bills at the
end because all these yeah yeah because
all these artists are like super humble
and they come up to me and like
brother's the biggest you know order
i've had in so long like you helped me
because i bought a lot around christmas
time like you paid for like my so
so-and-so's gifts like thank you thank
you good [ __ ] damn like this is awesome
you know i mean like it's just it's a
cool cool little feeling yeah yeah you
do the recipe man you're doing what you
like and you're [ __ ] not hurting
anybody and you're all you're just
helping yeah yeah for sure you got to
win what you got to do that's what you
got to do
man thank you thank you [ __ ] yeah dude
so everybody can find you at
ericon.ig on instagram yes here you guys
youtube
eric aircon on youtube aircon no dots no
underscores no nothing just the name
aircon you said anova
smoke.com yes sure yeah we ran we rant
out here right all right try to i try to
draw that back in like 20 minutes ago we
just kept going i'm sorry you just
dropped the bomb i mean god damn i know
how did you not bring this [ __ ] up man
oh [ __ ]
that's sick thank you [ __ ] yeah
that's the most major [ __ ] that you
could have done yeah because once that
[ __ ] gets big and they go oh we'll go
in the marketplace oh you cashed out oh
10 mil oh thanks
that's how that [ __ ] goes down yeah yeah
for sure
ooh excited for you man that's how it's
gonna work undisclosed company well
right undisclosed uh there's a certain
company i know you work with and we'll
just say you saw that they sold the
other day oh yeah you know what i'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah that
[ __ ] got cashed out do you know
how much money that man made a lot a lot
of millions off of that
oh we're gonna crush this yeah that's
how you feel like with yours that's the
potential you're saying right right for
sure it's exciting it's exciting dude
it's exciting for sure well awesome dude
so everybody out there
neither of us get paid on this youtube
[ __ ] so go ahead and help us out in
other ways bye hello tell the
[ __ ] to watch yeah you like some
glass you like some [ __ ] man buy it for
a friend maybe buy it for yourself we're
not saying to go buy these things
youtube we're just saying
by the way
it's out there for research
i just bought spoken yesterday you know
we sell this too that's us that does
with youtube you know we don't get paid
[ __ ]
um all right we're just i'm just gonna
keep going and rant my bad thank you for
being here man i don't know how long we
are here but thank you for being here
that was really [ __ ] good that's in
all stores el blentos everywhere i've
seen them in all the dispensaries
so you can get the anova ice hatch that
the only ice house one they got
i might at the time right now yeah it's
just bomb dude and i would have puffed
on it only if it wasn't bomb but i
smoked it so
you see it i did like it it was very
good yeah it was good
thank you for being here man uh you've
been back you've officially been here
with me three times three times
well two solos now oh yeah you were in
the season one and then we did one with
goblin together
and then here you are again i like the
update you've been here for nine months
bro
you moved here now you own part of a
legal wii company
nine months later i'm excited i'm very
excited for you this is cool yeah
there's not a lot of people out there
that i actually look at and watch and go
good [ __ ] [ __ ] because they're
doing it right right there's not a lot
and i know you know that yeah yeah not a
lot of people that are like oh that's a
great move
so congratulations man on everything
thank you for being here so much marty
thank you for being here thank you guys
keto what's your dog's name kento kento
kento that's where all he's talking
about chillin back here he loves you he
loves your ass
so thank you for being here man
everybody out there thank you for
watching go check out eric's stuff
online go watch youtube you have to type
it all the way in
all right
shadow man go watch that [ __ ] thanks for
being here man appreciate you so much
appreciate you thank you thank you until
next time guys i am as yola have a dope
ass day
damn that was fun that was fun that was
a good one hell yeah
wow they give you equity oh [ __ ]
oh good [ __ ]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]